So Leute, Hackermans-Time, guck mal wie gut das funktioniert.
Mal die Namen hier oben eingeplendet lassen, weil wir müssen ja alle wissen, dass Salziger
Hoden der Top-Gifter ist.
So, leise machen, ein bisschen laut.
Warum hat man sich bei Microsoft eigentlich gedacht, das müssen hier Zweier-Schritte sein?
Warum ging nicht Einser-Schritte?
Weiß man nicht.
Microsoft-Logik.
So.
Ich bin echt mal gespannt, was das Portalzeug taugt.
Also angeblich kann man ja hier, vielleicht warte ich noch mal kurz bis es losgeht, ich
hab mich hier eingeloggt, also angeblich kann man ja hier so eigene Spielmodi bauen, in
dieser Variante hier.
Und das probieren wir mal aus.
Ich hab keinen Schürmer, wie gut das funktioniert.
Ich bin skeptisch, dass man da viel mit machen kann.
Und ich dachte mir, wir bauen mal Noshakannels TDM mit Killstreaks.
Mal gucken, ob das wirklich ist.
Schauen wir mal.
Und dann auch mal gucken, wie sich's spielt.
Also ob das überhaupt da funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Massive High-Speed-Notification, ja.
Richtig schnell.
Kann man im Portalmodus nicht leveln?
Doch.
Was genau meinst du mit Killstreaks?
Na ja, man kann hier den angeblich eigenen Spielmodus designen.
Das probieren wir mal.
Wir probieren mal Noshakannels TDM mit Killstreaks zu bauen.
Mal gucken, ob das was wird.
Ich bin ja skeptisch.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Und ich weiß jetzt schon, dass dieser komische Logik, wie heißt?
Rules Editor heißt, glaube ich.
Mich abfacken wird hoch drei.
Warum könnten sie nicht für die Leute, die programmieren,
können irgendeinen JavaScript, Pysen oder sonst was dabei packen,
anstatt das da?
Das ist ja wirklich ganz, ganz grausig.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich glaube, das ist so beschränkt.
Da kann man gar nichts Großartiges vergleichen.
Aber ja, es ist wahrscheinlich besser als C++,
weil eigentlich alles besser als C++ ist.
So, wir klicken uns mal schnell was zusammen,
dass wir zum Logik Editor kommen.
Also, wir createn something new.
So, wir spielen TDM.
Hier halte ich mich jetzt nicht zu lang auf.
Ich klick das jetzt einfach nur schnell durch.
Ich will jetzt zu diesem Rules Editor.
TDM, Map Rotation.
Gibt es hier eine Suche?
NOSHA, NOSHA Candles Container.
Ja, POG, beste.
Game Mode Details, Human Players.
Komm, 48.
48 geht gerade noch so.
NOSHA TDM, Team Distribution 24, 24, Spawn Type.
Ist mir alles egal.
Gameplay, Friendly Fire, alles Default.
Soldier, alles Default, Default, Default.
AI.
Bots.
Bots machen wir mal, weil ich muss den Kram testen.
Wenn ich den Kram testen muss.
Hallo?
Hä?
Klappt es jetzt?
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert jetzt.
PvE AI, PvP AI.
Ah, PvE heißt, die greifen mich an sich selbst untereinander nicht, oder was?
Also Bots mache ich mal ein paar rein.
Damit ich das überhaupt testen kann am Ende.
24 müssten ja gehen.
Sag mal so 20.
Ich muss auf jeder Seite.
Ach so, Moment.
Ja, so.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Ich brauche ein paar Bots, dass man das, immer mal ein bisschen weniger.
Dass man das testen kann, gescheit.
Kann man die Bots dumm stellen?
Hier, Difficulty, Beginner.
Perfekt.
Ich brauche das ja nur zum Testen, weil ich gehe mal davon aus, dass meine Logik nicht direkt funktionieren wird.
So, Teams, wir wollen Battlefield 3.
Und das wäre natürlich auch cool, wenn man hier mehrere Klassen, weil dann könnte man quasi
Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 1 und Battlefield sonst wie Klassen.
Das wäre halt unbalanced as fuck, aber mein, warum nicht?
Ja, das können wir alles drinnen lassen, das interessiert mich nicht.
Weapons, wir lassen alles Default.
Alles Default.
Okay.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Kann man das speichern?
Weil ich habe keinen Bock, dass mein Browser abkackt und es dann kaputt ist.
Kann man Server Message machen oder sowas?
Message.
Also wir testen jetzt, wir testen mal was ganz Simples.
Wir testen mal was ganz Simples.
Wir machen eine Schleife, die alle 5 Sekunden Hallo Cute Chat schreibt.
Hier oben rechts beim Ordner.
Ah.
Name.
Äh, ja.
Cute, BDM.
Nose, Hair, Skills, Speaks, Create.
Ah, jetzt, wenn die Steuerung S drückt, speichert es dann auch.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Wäre ja auch zu einfach.
So, wenn ich jetzt hier was ändere.
Äh, Logic.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ah, okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
GG Eats.
Dem Panda.
Ach, Panda.
Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Alles klar.
Äh, ja.
Danke für den Sub.
Ist das Scratch?
Mir sagt das gar nichts.
Trutz.
Dankeschön.
Sub.
Massive.
Huge Subscription.
Hier, Scratch.
Kenn ich nicht.
Was?
Scratch.
Ja, okay, jetzt ist es doch.
Es hat doch gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, ja.
Stimmt.
Das kannte ich nicht.
Ist das irgendwas zu programmieren, wie für die Grundschule oder was?
Ja, ist tatsächlich relativ ähnlich.
Okay, ich versuche jetzt mal was ganz Simples.
Einfach eine Message machen.
Stink noch mal eine Message, die alle paar Sekunden kommt.
Wie geht das?
Wie geht das denn?
Okay.
Event ongoing.
Äh, in welchem Intervall?
Oder so schnell es geht, Server kackt ab.
Ah, ah, help.
Ah, big brain time.
Massive file fat.
Wie viel Zeit haben die dafür investiert?
Angeblich über ein Jahr wurde das parallel zum Rest entwickelt, habe ich gelesen.
Also, was hier?
Wie?
Moment, Zach.
Ongoing.
Aha.
Ongoing Event.
Continuously check if condition becomes true.
Ah ja.
Okay, das ist keine Schleife.
Das ist keine Schleife.
Gibt es hier Schleifen?
Ich mache mal kurz ein bisschen größer.
Ach nee, das geht nicht.
Aber man kann, glaube ich, alles ganz gut erkennen, Chet, oder?
Naja, ich lasse mal auf 100 Prozent, sonst wird es zu fett.
Four, loop, while.
Kann man denn hier alles machen?
Array, count off, slice, quick muffs.
Hiyoyoy.
Jetzt wird es aber big brain time player.
Control action.
Ah, loop, while.
Okay, gut.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Wir machen einfach...
Nee, das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Okay, ich will nichts anderes als eine Schleife, die alle fünf Sekunden eine Message ausgibt.
Also, action, ongoing, meinetwegen.
In it, oder so.
So, das erste Mal ein einziges.
Jetzt ist die Frage, wenn Condition leer ist, wird es dann ausgeführt, oder muss es eine
Condition geben?
Logic.
Logic?
Ah, hier.
If equals.
Okay, ich glaube, so geht das nicht.
Gibt es so etwas wie true?
So, constants?
Is true?
Ah, guck mal, Variablen haben wir auch.
Manage.
Okay, 16 Variablen kommt man damit hin?
Ah, das ist aber...
Es gibt Arrays.
Ja, gut, das kann man als Variablen missbrauchen.
Gibt es auch Diktionaries?
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Okay.
Conditions, wie kriege ich denn da jetzt eine Condition rein?
Ah, Condition.
Equals.
Und gibt es sowas wie true?
Gibt es irgendwie pool?
False?
True?
WTF sind Diktionaries?
So was wie, ich überlege gerade, gibt es da was Allgemeineres?
Hashtable?
Falls du Java programmierst.
Ein Diktionary ist quasi wie ein Array, nur dass du als Index keine Zahlen verwenden kannst,
sondern alles, was du willst.
Ja, Wörterbuch.
Ich glaube, das kann man sich aber auch wenig darunter vorstellen.
Warum macht man sowas?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Gibt es einfach true?
Guck mal, Literals gibt es da.
Ach ja, schau mal da.
Ah, Big Brain.
Beste Condition aller Zeiten.
If Condition true.
So muss das sein.
So, jetzt weiß man Bescheid.
Okay, wie kriege ich denn die Message hier jetzt angezeigt?
Okay.
Moment, kann man das Copy Pasten?
Okay, das ist schon mal nice.
True?
Und jetzt brauchen wir Sleep.
Sleep.
Delay.
Wait.
Ah, jetzt.
Und jetzt bestimmt Literals.
Oh, Big Brain.
Oh, sind das überhaupt Sekunden, die man hier waitet?
Seconds.
Oh, wer hat sich denn das ausgedacht?
Ich habe instinktlich hier oben nach dem Schließenknopf gedrückt,
aber hier ist unten so ein Ding.
Was ist das denn?
Gibt es einen Timer?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Timer.
Ah, nee, Timer Remaining.
Gibt keinen Timer.
Clock?
Nö.
Oben in dem Blockby Event.
Ach, da gibt es einen Timer?
Nö.
Gibt keinen Timer.
Timelimit reached?
Nee, gibt es nicht.
Top, wir müssen das so machen.
So, wait.
So, jetzt will ich eine Message schicken.
Wie schicke ich denn jetzt eine Message im Server?
Ach, nee, das ist nun ein String, der Message heißt.
User Interface?
Nee.
Nee, nee.
Ich will eine Message auf.
Ach, hier.
Display Game Mode mit Display Custom Message.
Clear Custom Message.
Display Notification Message.
Okay.
Okay, dann wait.
Alter, ich will die Reihenfolge verändern.
Dann waiten wir mal, wenn das für 6...
Displayed 6 Seconds, dann warten wir einfach 5 Sekunden und...
Boah, die Frage ist jetzt, blockt das für 6 Sekunden?
Oder nicht?
Oh mein Lieber, 10 Sekunden.
Das weiß man ja nicht, ne?
So, und jetzt Message.
Hier kommt die Message rein.
Monkeys, wie zum...
Geht das?
String?
Ah ja.
Ach, guck mal mal, die haben sogar Templates drinne.
Event Player, get Game Mode Score.
Na, das ist egal.
Ich will einfach nur mal testen, wie es funktioniert.
Ich will einfach ganz stinknormal eine Message anzeigen.
Alle 10 Sekunden.
Text.
Kek W größer Lul W.
Save.
So, wenn das jetzt klappt, so wie ich mir das vorstelle...
Dann sollte das alle 10 Sekunden für 6 Sekunden lang...
Die Message Kek W größer Lul W anzeigen.
Das sind Parameter hier hinten.
Und hier hinten kann man den Player wahrscheinlich...
Ach so, und Team.
Ne, ich will es ja für alle anzeigen.
Da fehlt noch ein Target.
Ne, da stand doch eben.
Wenn es kein Target hat, wird es zu allen gezeigt.
If no Target, it will display to message everyone.
Das ist okay.
Alles klar.
So, als Test reicht es jetzt mal.
Wie spielt man das jetzt?
So ein Simulator wäre irgendwie cool, der das so durchspielt.
Aber gibt es nicht.
Ähm.
Hm.
Showcode?
Afaskaftsk.
Okay.
Ach, der.
Okay, Copy.
Besser.
Den nehmen wir jetzt.
Das ist der Code, den wir brauchen.
Starten wir mal.
Hallo, ich möchte das gerne playen.
Game.
Okay.
So ein Run- oder Testknopf hat das.
Ah, Zoom.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Schauen wir mal.
Da bin ich jetzt mal wirklich gespannt.
Also alle 5 Sekunden eine Message anzeigen.
Ne.
6 Sekunden lang eine Message anzeigen und dann 10 Sekunden sleepen.
Und dann nochmal neu.
Nein, da machen wir keine Prediction.
Wenn das schon nicht funktioniert, dann müssen wir den Rest das gar nicht weiter probieren.
Pass auf, jetzt Server down oder so.
Okay, Portal.
Post.
Custom.
Nice.
Guck mal da.
Kann ich jetzt da meinen Code eingeben irgendwie auch?
Befall?
Ich habe keinen Freefall angelegt?
Doch, ich habe einen Freefall angelegt, als der Portal Editor geleakt ist.
Code oben rechts.
Ah.
Ah, Copy Paste geht nicht.
Na, das geht ja gut los.
A, F, H, S, V, Confirm.
Da steht ja nichts dazu da.
Post Server.
Code TDM.
Ah, sauber.
Ernsthaft?
Wie jetzt wirklich?
Ist das euer Ernst?
Der Scheiß geht nicht oder was?
Ah, das ist der Secret.
PQ.
Off.
Global Game Quota Exceeded.
Gibt es einen Guide dazu?
Ich meine, das Spiel jetzt ja nur die Pre-Order, Leute.
Related to the Issue.
Was?
Exceeded.
Das ist doch wieder Chebathe-Artikel, oder?
If you're seeing, we are aware of this issue.
Ja.
Weckt mich.
Was soll das?
Wait a minute.
Warum ist hier im Inkognito-Modus Werbung?
Sack.
Weitere Tools, Erweiterung.
Details.
Das kann man doch auch im Inkognito-Modus anschauen.
Jawoll.
Weg damit.
Okay, das heißt, wir können nur ein bisschen, ja.
Can you fix?
Alter, diese Nonsens-Artikel immer.
I wonder why.
Wie viel Server dürfen denn weltweit aufgemacht werden?
Wir gucken jetzt mal, ob das einfach nur ein Fix ist gegen XP-Server.
Sack.
Wartet mal.
Post.
Official Experience by the Company Rush.
Das ist ein Fix gegen die XP-Server.
Die haben das ausgeschaltet, dass man Custom-Games hausten kann.
Wann kommt das Spiel raus vor drei Tagen?
Was ein Scheiß, Mann.
Was?
Oh Mann.
Ach so, jetzt habe ich das gehostet.
Und ist es jetzt, ist es jetzt weg oder?
Ach, das ist nur so lange gehostet.
Moment.
Läuft das nur so lange, wie ich selber drauf bin?
Dann im Endeffekt oder was?
Kann man da keinen Server aufmachen, der aufbleibt?
Hier kann man auch nicht suchen, so wirklich.
Solange die Leute drauf sind, okay.
XP-Farm, all welcome.
Hätten da nichts XP gefarmt, testen wir jetzt mal.
Garantiert wird da nichts XP gefarmt.
Müssen wir jetzt mal testen, ich mache mal kurz hier die Game Capture an.
Warte mal, Game Capture?
Was hatten wir, Game Capture oder Window Capture?
Ich glaube, Game Capture.
Ist das jetzt, was ist daran XP-Farm?
Sack.
Muss ich jetzt ausprobieren.
Ich kann doch nicht mal spawnen.
Easy XP-Farm.
Hallo, ich darf nicht mal spawnen, ah jetzt, okay.
Was ist, das, what the fuck, das ist Messer only?
Oder was, oder wie, oder, hä?
Okay, das ist dumm.
Die haben das, die haben das einfach ausgeschaltet.
Jetzt haben die sich denn da wieder überlegt.
Moment, Moment, wait a minute.
Warum habe, warum habe ich nur, nur ein Messer und der Typ hat eine Waffe?
Das erscheint mir sehr fair zu sein.
Ein Team Gun, ein Team Only Knife, lull.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ich bin der Bot, ja.
So Schwachsinn.
Exit, ja ja, ist gut.
Ich bin der, der gewarnt wird, XP.
Das ist ja dumm.
Aber ich will meinen eigenen Kram hosten können.
Host.
Das haben die gemacht zum Fixen von Boost-Servern.
Sagt euch, jetzt kann man den Kram noch nicht mal ausprobieren.
Mein Gott, ist das bescheuert.
Sehr gut, wir können ja hier ein bisschen weiter bauen und sobald es geht, dann ausprobieren.
Vielleicht wegen der Bots.
Weißt du, weil ich Bots rein gemacht habe?
Das können wir noch mal ausprobieren.
Warum nicht die XP ausgestellt?
Das ist wahrscheinlich, weil es dann kein Mensch spielen würde.
Das können wir tatsächlich, weil wir können die Bots ausschalten.
Ich meine, das scheuen ja genug von euch drauf.
Wo waren das hier mit Bots?
AI.
Bot count.
No AI.
Default.
Muss ich das jetzt alles noch mal neu durchklicken?
Nee, oder?
Ich hätte es auflassen sollen.
Aber eigentlich bin ich hier scharf drauf. Ich wollte jetzt ja nur ausprobieren, ob es funktioniert.
Und warum startet das Game vor allem drei Stunden?
Pre-Order Now.
Ja, ist wichtig.
Ich habe das Game noch nicht für Xbox und Playstation noch mal gekauft, solange bleibt es jetzt oben stehen.
Okay, dann überlegen wir uns, wie wir das machen könnten und spielen es halt, sobald es funktioniert.
Okay, Portal House. Darf ich jetzt Qt TDM?
Ach ja, das ist wegen der Bots.
Die Bots wurden deaktiviert.
Okay, Moment, ich muss den Server, sorry Leute, ich gehe noch mal raus.
Ich muss den Server ordentlich benennen, weil das findet ihr ja nicht.
KekW 0W.
Das müsste jetzt alle, jetzt zehn Sekunden Downtime und dann müsst...
Es funktioniert, Leute.
KekW 0W.
Jawoll.
Es funktioniert.
Endlosschleife.
Funktioniert, nice.
Wie startet das nicht?
Ich meine, es bringt ja auch gar nichts übrigens, wenn ihr jointen.
By the way, das hat keinen Sinn, es ist ja noch nichts drauf.
So war das...
Nein, so war das in Battlefield 3 nicht, dass man das sliden konnte.
Okay, das funktioniert schon mal.
Da bin ich beruhigt.
Dann gehen wir mal raus, Leaf Game, Exit.
Also das funzt, sehr schön, sehr, sehr gut.
Excellent.
Kannst du damit auch eine...
Ich kann damit bestimmt den Server abschießen, das geht.
So, wunderbar.
Excellent.
Also, das funktioniert schon mal.
Jetzt können wir...
Alter, wie das laggt.
Das ist, weil Battlefield im Hintergrund läuft.
Kann man dem irgendwie abgewöhnen, dass der so viel CPU frisst?
Ich meine, der frisst meine ganze CPU im Ladebildschirm.
Der frisst meine ganze CPU im Hauptmenü.
Vsync und kann man FPS limit oder sowas.
Display.
Wo ist es denn?
Wenn ich jetzt...
Vsync on.
Vsync on und wir machen jetzt einfach refresh rate 30.
Ne, cineastisch.
Cineastisch.
Cineastische 25 Hertz.
Blei.
Guckt euch den Mauszeiger an.
Cineastische 25 Hertz.
Jawoll.
So, ist es jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen...
Alter!
Warum frisst du so viel CPU?
Was macht das Game denn, bitteschön?
Was sagt der denn?
Einfach CPU Upgrade.
Genau.
Ja, das ist dumm, wenn man das Spiel im Hintergrund nicht laufen lässt.
Man muss doch die CPU Usage von dem Game irgendwie runterkriegen.
Warum auf...
Windowed?
Borderless Window?
Ah, naja.
Okay, es ist schon ein bisschen weniger.
Im Borderless Window, aber trotzdem.
Alter, das Tracking Drop hier ist ja nicht normal, wenn du das Game im Hintergrund laufen hast.
BF2052 CPU Usage.
Ja, zeig her.
Fix.
Ja, ich will das fixen.
Powerplan?
Was?
Schwachsinn.
Das ist doch Blödsinn.
Halt! Das ist doch Schwachsinn!
So, kann man die FPS irgendwie limitieren? Geht das?
Jetzt ruckelt das Stream anscheinend.
Aber nur in-Game, wenn ich hier außerhalb...
Ach nee. Oh Mann! Please!
Okay, ich habe eine Idee, wie ich das fixen kann.
Windowed? Okay, das geht nicht.
Yes.
Okay, jetzt ist es wenigstens flüssig.
Refresh Rate.
F5 war ein Scherz, doch Schwachsinn.
Yes.
Konnte man das nicht FPS limitieren?
Task Manager Priorität runter. Das ist tatsächlich eine ziemlich gute Idee, das machen wir jetzt.
Aber ich meine ernsthaft, warum frisst es denn so viel?
Ach guck mal, wenn man in die Karten geht, in die Cards geht, ist es besser.
Kann es sein, dass es der Anti-Cheat ist, der nicht will, dass man im Hintergrund was macht?
Check. Guckt euch mal, wie langsam das aufbaut, das kann es doch nicht sein.
Was ist denn hier? Battlefield?
Wo stellt man das ein?
Ah, Set Priority Low. Yes.
Wie startet man den Task Manager überhaupt mit Admin? So, gut.
Excellent.
Ja, mein PC ist eindeutig zu schlecht dafür. Set Priority Low.
Okay, weißt du was? Wir müssen das gar nicht auflassen im Hintergrund, wir probieren das eh nicht so oft aus.
So, guck mal. Schon geht es instant flüssig.
Das ist nichts für geringe Verdiener, unter 16 Kerne geht da nichts.
Okay, also. Jetzt machen wir mal was Sinnvolles.
Also ich habe mir überlegt, was man als Skills in der Auflösung runter, in der Auflösung runter geht nur im Fullscreen und dann schaltest du sie überall runter.
Also dann sieht es wahrscheinlich mein Desktop die Icons verschoben und alles.
Weil das wollen wir aber diesem Desktop nicht, dass die Icons sich verschieben.
Also ich habe mir überlegt, was gut wäre als Kills-Tweaks.
Ich glaube, auf Linux soll es angeblich mit ein paar Tweaks wohl laufen, habe ich gelesen.
Aber wie gut das ist und ob du als Cheater erkannt wirst, so weiß ich nicht.
Also Kills-Tweaks, was man zum Beispiel machen könnte, habe ich mir überlegt.
Man könnte zum Beispiel spotten, alle für keine Ahnung, 15 Sekunden.
Dann könnte man zum Beispiel Smoke, Smoke falls das geht.
Es darf ja auch nicht zu übertrieben sein, es muss machbar sein.
So, Ammo-Box vielleicht, dass man selbst Ammo droppt oder Ammo-Refill.
Irgendwas kleines. Ja Nuke könnte man machen, Nuke ist wahrscheinlich sogar relativ einfach.
Nuke könnte man machen mit einfach alle Spieler töten.
Aber wir müssen eh mal gucken, wie man überhaupt was anwenden kann auf alle Spieler.
Wir probieren das mal mit Spotten.
Smoke, Spotten, Ammo-Box könnte man zum Beispiel machen.
Heal 100%, einmal irgendwie sowas.
Wir probieren das mal mit Spotten aus, würde ich sagen.
Das erscheint mir relativ easy.
Wobei, mal gucken, wenn eine Message schon so ein Klumpen hier ist, mal schauen.
Die Warlag-Ability von einem Spezialisten, ja das müssen wir mal schauen.
Ich habe aber Battlefield 3 eingestellt, mal schauen, mal schauen.
So als erstes müssen wir uns irgendwie überlegen.
Ich überlege gerade, mit was wir anfangen.
Gucken wir, wie man zuerst alle Player spotten kann oder gucken wir, wie wir irgendwie Killstreaks tracken kann.
Ich würde sagen, wir gucken, wie man Player spotten kann.
Weil Spot habe ich eben schon gesehen.
Spot Target.
Ok, was muss da rein?
Spot Target, Spot Target Player for Specific Duration.
Ok, Duration ist einfach, da wissen wir schon, wie das funktioniert.
Wir spotten den Player.
Ich denke, ein ganz guter Killstreak ist, keine Ahnung, 15 Sekunden oder so.
10 Sekunden Player spotten alle.
Das reicht.
So, keine Ahnung.
So ein 3er Killstreak.
Es ist zwar quasi Blackbird, aber 3er Kills.
Ja, sind zwar ausprobieren, ist glaube ich ganz ok.
Ok, so Spot, Spot Target.
Jetzt brauchen wir eine Schleife.
Jetzt brauchen wir eine Schleife über alle Player.
Ok.
Gibt es for each?
Es gibt while.
Kann man while auf den Array machen?
Array?
Oh, empty Array.
Ok, da muss irgendwie for each loop.
Ok, ach du Scheiße.
Wie machen wir jetzt da einen for each über alle Player?
Und?
Gibt es player?
Ah ja, ok, get players, get player state.
Ich versuche Noshat TDR mit Killstreaks zu bauen.
Mach doch UAV, ich weiß nicht, wie man Hohen spawned auf der Map.
So.
Set Player Soldier, Set Player Max Health.
Ok, hiermit können wir die Nuke bauen.
Undeploy all.
Event other player?
Es ist ja kein Event, ich will eine Schleife machen.
Level all deploy.
Ok, get players.
Get players.
From oder for get players?
Count.
Count?
Count of?
Ah, count of get players.
From to count of get players?
Ok, ach du Scheiße.
Oh, das ist Cancer.
Oh, das wird eklig.
Sind die Arrays zero indexed?
Was kannst du get players in spot target ziehen?
Gute Frage.
Das wäre natürlich cool, aber das geht nicht.
So.
From zero to count of players?
Loop Variable.
Muss ich da einen meiner 16 globalen Variablen für opfern?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Hier, Loop.
Get Variable.
Ne.
Ah, ne.
Hä?
Ne.
Ah, doch.
Boah, ist das eklig.
Alter, ist das eklig.
MonkaS.
Ok.
Dabei ist wahrscheinlich, ob ich einfach zweifach oder vierfach oder irgendwie so.
Ok, also.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, gibt es jetzt, ist das single threaded die Events oder multithreaded?
Wenn es multithreaded ist, crash das instant und geht überhaupt nicht.
No-Code-Plattformen werden uns arbeitslos sein, ja.
Eindeutig, wenn du zwei Wochen für simpelste Dinge brauchst.
Ich weiß ja auch überhaupt nicht, was das sein soll, ehrlich gesagt, dieses Emote.
Ich meine, klar, das soll was hier mit KegW zu tun haben, aber ich verstehe den Sinn nicht.
Das sieht ja mal richtig, richtig mies aus im Vergleich zum Original.
Die könnten, die könnten Javascript da reinbauen oder so, dass da irgendwie programmieren kannst ordentlich.
Ok.
So, wir haben jetzt ne Vorschleife über die Index von.
Von Allplayer.
So, das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt sowas wie GetIndex oder sowas.
Index.
Ach guck mal hier.
Set variable at index.
Set index of array value.
Index of array value.
Sowas in der Richtung will ich haben.
Return the index of an array value.
Also, das heißt, wir brauchen noch mal GetPlayers.
Wenn sich GetPlayers an Zwischenzeit geändert hat, wird das nicht funktionieren.
Aber ich hoffe nicht, dass es multithreaded ist.
Ich hoffe, das ist alles schön single threaded, weil ansonsten funktioniert das ganze Ding hinten und vorne nicht.
Kannst du GetPlayers in ein Array stopfen?
GetPlayers returnt ein Array.
Ich könnte eine Variable mit GetPlayers machen.
Das Problem ist nur, dass ich nur 16 globale Variablen zur Verfügung habe.
Wir gucken mal, ob das von der Logik her überhaupt so klappt.
Und jetzt habe ich index array value.
Also, hier kommt jetzt quasi der...
Was muss denn da jetzt rein?
Ach so, hier muss der Index rein, welchen ich haben will.
Der Index ist ja... Moment, der Index ist ja das hier.
Der Index ist ja das, was in meinem... Hä?
Ach, müssen wir das erst noch get... variable?
GetVariable, alles klar.
Nee.
Ach, du scheiße Sack.
Also, was muss ich jetzt machen?
So, hier, hä?
Nee.
Ah, so rum?
Wo muss da was rein?
GetPlayers muss vorne rein.
Ach nee, returns the index, nicht das Element.
Das gibt den Index zurück.
Moment, wo kriege ich denn das Element dann her?
Value?
Returns the value... Ah, okay, okay.
Excellent, excellent.
Alles klar.
Ich sehe schon, alle Programmierer werden instant arbeitslos, wenn dieses Tool kommt.
Das stellt ja alles in den Schatten.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist mega umständlich alles.
Also, sowas da, hä?
Loop.
Loop, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das aussprechen soll jetzt.
From null to count of players.
Ähm.
Und dann spots target.
Alle, alle Spieler spotten für 10 Sekunden.
Ob das funktioniert?
Ob das klappt?
Wär ja gut.
Wo sehen wir das denn mal aus?
Da müsst ihr jetzt aber joinen dazu, um zu gucken, dass das klappt.
Es werden alle gespottet jetzt, ja.
Nein, man kann leider nicht einfach Skript schreiben.
Leider nicht, das wäre mir auch lieber.
Hallo, ich möchte gerne dieses...
Kann ich das nicht lösen irgendwie hier raus?
Nein.
Hallo?
Boah, das ist ja abartig.
So, save.
Okay, wir spotten, wir spotten alle, wir spotten alle 20 Sekunden.
Alle Spieler für 10 Sekunden.
Muss doch mal schauen, ob das jetzt klappt.
Lass mal kurz, bevor ich ein Spiel aufmache, lass mal kurz überprüfen.
While true.
Wait 20, okay.
Display notification, das lassen wir da.
Loop from null to count players.
Probieren wir es aus.
Der Byword, nee, der Byword würde ich sagen ist...
Intervall, vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht muss ich den setzen.
Null, null, nein, by one.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Ich mache jetzt mal einen Server auf mit einem Name, den ihr suchen könnt.
Und dann müssen wir ausprobieren, ob wir gespottet werden.
Aber wie gesagt, Leute, ich mache das dann gleich wieder zu.
Ich mache aber ein Passwort drauf.
Passwort ist keqwe, groß geschrieben alles.
Das ist kein Hot Reload, nee.
Das ist glaube ich so ziemlich das Gegenteil von Hot Reload.
Das ist Hot Cold Start.
Ich glaube, viel undynamischer geht es nicht mehr.
Ich kann es ja leider auch nicht richtig laufen lassen, weil da eine CPU am Anschlag ist.
Kportal, Host, Custom, Host, Name, Qt, zusammen geschrieben Qt, Tdm.
0w, Passwort, keqwe, Host Server.
Kann es sein, dass es einfach doch aus irgendwelchen Gründen überlastet ist?
Hallo, ich möchte programmieren lernen.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Sekunde.
Ich muss mal kurz in den Chat gucken.
Hallo, ich möchte programmieren lernen.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Sprache empfiehlt ihr mir diesen?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ja, das ist doch, das ist doch Chebat.
Bis zu diesem Punkt habe ich noch geglaubt, aber ab hier wird es Chebat, Alter.
Ab hier wird es Massive Chebat.
Ah, jetzt geht es.
Leute, Qt, Tdm, auf geht es.
Wir müssen testen, ob das Spotten funktioniert.
Vielleicht sollte ich es nochmal mit Bots probieren.
Vielleicht lag es gar nicht an Bots.
Ich mache Bots gleich nochmal rein.
Nein, Qt, Tdm, besuchen, Passwort, keqwe.
Also die Message, mit der Message funktioniert das schon mal.
Kann mich das Game please starten lassen?
Nein, die Message ist drin, das ist Absicht.
Da ist schon einer, guck mal hier.
Das ist das Squad. Guck mal, ob ihr das Game überhaupt findet.
Ich mache jetzt gleich nochmal Bots rein.
Ich warte jetzt mal, ob irgendwie einer Bock hat zu joinen, um das auszuprobieren.
Wenn nicht, mache ich Bots an.
Final Regime mit Portal invertieren, ja.
Gute Idee.
Guck mal, das läuft innerhalb des Games besser.
Findet ihr keinen Qt, Tdm?
Aber guck mal, wir haben einen Gegner.
Guck mal, der wird gespottet.
Guck mal, er wird gespottet.
Das funktioniert.
Er wurde gerade gespottet.
Nee, er schießt, aber er wurde eben auch gespottet.
Guck hier, seht ihr, er wird gespottet.
Nice, hier.
Das ist ja wie Orbi.
Seht ihr mich auch? Ja, ja, ja.
Guck, da ist er.
Guck mal, er wird gespottet.
Ich habe ihn nicht gespottet, der Server spottet ihn.
Oh, mega Aim, Alter.
Poggers, nice, das funktioniert, das ist ja cool.
Funktioniert, nice.
Okay, ich gehe wieder raus, Leute.
Wir wissen jetzt, dass es funktioniert.
Ich habe gequittet.
Das zum Ausprobieren ist natürlich...
Die Message, die Message lassen wir drinne.
Die Message lassen wir drinne.
Okay, machen wir das hier mal raus.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich noch mal Bots reinmachen kann.
Und ob das dann vielleicht geht mit Hosten.
Bots.
Moment, wo war das noch mal mit Bots?
AI.
Save.
Probieren wir gleich aus.
Okay, also jetzt kommt das Schwierigste überhaupt.
Also vermute ich mal, wir müssen tracken, wer welche Killstreaks hat.
Kills, kann man überhaupt Kills irgendwie?
Killplayer?
Okay, ich habe eine Idee.
Also das Ding können wir ja schon mal gut gebrauchen.
Loop über alle Spieler.
Ich habe nämlich da was gesehen.
Wir können Subroutines machen.
Subroutines, also quasi Funktionen aufrufen.
Ach so, nee, das bringt ja nichts, weil es ist ja unterschiedlich, was ich da drin machen will.
Aber lass mal kurz ausprobieren.
Create.
Parameter?
Das hat keine Parameter?
Ja, das ist ja useless.
Dann kann man das auch einfach komplett weglassen.
Subroutine ohne Parameter.
Ja, sehr sinnvoll.
Okay, man könnte es irgendwie über globale Variablen machen.
Aber wozu dann nicht einfach alles inline schreiben?
Okay, also das mit dem Spotten ist schon mal nice.
Das funktioniert.
So, die Notification, die lasse ich drinnen, dass ich weiß, wann das tickt.
So, wie können wir jetzt tracken, wer wie viele Kills hat?
Also die normalen Variablen können wir auf jeden Fall nicht verwenden.
Weil da haben wir bloß 16 Stück und 16 Player.
Wir haben ja schon 48 Spieler.
Gibt es onKill?
Ja, das gibt es.
Aber einfach nur onKill++ zu machen ist nicht das Ding.
Man müsste quasi onKill, sich das speichern, also onKill++++ und onDeath müsste man gleich null machen.
Also mit globalen Variablen.
Wir könnten einen Array machen.
Ja, doch Leute, ich habe eine Idee.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das sinnig ist.
Wenn ihr bessere Ideen habt, sagt Bescheid.
Wir machen einen Array und jedes Mal, wenn der Spieler einen Kill macht,
pushen wir ihn in das Array und jedes Mal, wenn er stirbt, löschen wir ihn komplett aus dem Array raus.
Das ist zwar nicht effizient, aber das ist das Einfachste, was mir jetzt einfällt.
Und jedes Mal, wenn er einen Kill macht, zählen wir, wie oft er in dem Array vorhanden ist.
Na, PlayerKillCount bringt ja nichts.
PlayerKillCount ist ja insgesamt.
Ich will ja Kills seit letztem Tod.
Ja, aber auch nur 16 Variablen, das ist zu wenig.
Also von der Idee her, müssten wir jetzt sowas sagen wie emptyArray.
Also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall eine globale Variable für das Array.
Kannst du nicht im Array Player++ machen?
Nö.
Ich kann da den Player drin speichern, aber irgendwie Custom Wert nicht.
PlayerKillCount purchen, wenn er stirbt.
Das geht bestimmt, dass ich PlayerKillCount purche, wenn er stirbt, aber dann hat er ja kein Scoreboard.
Max, mach eine Streak Variable als Instanz Variable an den Spieler.
Ha!
Lull.
Ja, weil das auch gerade funktioniert hier drin.
Weil das auch gerade so sophisticated ist, dass das funktioniert.
Klar, wenn ich irgendwelche Custom Variablen attachen könnte an das Spielerelement, ja
dann wäre das easy.
Kann ich aber nicht.
Sowas gibt es hier nicht.
Nee, einen Dictionary gibt es nicht.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt mal so, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Also wenn es sowas geben würde, wären mir auch schon einiges eingefallen.
Wir müssen das mit den Mitteln machen, die...
Was du?
So verstehst du Object?
Moment, wo ist hier Object Variablen?
Moment.
Wo?
Hä?
Wo sind hier Object Variablen?
Ach so.
Player?
Hm.
Moment, Moment.
Ist das vielleicht wirklich sowas?
Gibt es diese Variablen einmal pro Spieler?
Ach sowas gibt es?
Ach das gibt es ja.
Ach das gibt es.
Ach wirklich?
Okay.
Das ist ja nice.
Ja gut, das können wir dann machen.
Also Kills.
Das müssen wir natürlich gleich mal ausprobieren, ob das tut.
Doch, bald Arbeitslos.
Sevenheads.
Kills.
So.
Euer Set Variable Global Player Kills 4.
Ach so.
Ja dann ist das ja einfach.
Dann ist das ja tatsächlich einfach.
Hier.
On.
Kill.
Das hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht.
Dass das funktioniert.
Massive.
Hier, On, On, On.
Ach Earned Kill.
Ich habe gerade etwas On Kill gesehen.
On Player Earned Kill Condition 2.
Braucht man diesen Müll überhaupt?
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht ausprobiert, ob es dann trotzdem ausführt.
Set Variable.
Player.
Das habe ich vorhin schon gesehen.
Es gab sowas hier wie Event oder sowas.
Player.
Event Player.
Ach so.
Ja.
Gibt es Increment?
Increment oder so?
Muffs.
Quick Muffs.
Add.
Ich mache das Get Variable Add.
Das ist natürlich ziemlich ppeger.
Aber.
In welcher Reihenfolge muss das hier?
Get Mode Score Event Player.
Ach hinten kommt es dann rein.
Add.
Player.
Kills.
Event Player.
Und jetzt 1.
So.
Also Player.
Add.
Also wir holen die Variable.
Adden 1 dazu und speichern es dann wieder in die Variable rein.
Ok.
Ja.
Das müsste funktionieren.
Ok.
Dann ist es tatsächlich in dem Fall einfach als mir das vorgestellt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man so Variable Sachen Attachen kann.
Das ist natürlich nice.
Ok.
On.
On Deploy muss ich hier machen, falls es sowas gibt.
On Player Deployed.
Ich muss es beim Respawn muss ich das resetten.
Weil.
Der Typ kann ja Revived werden.
Jetzt ist.
Leute was meint ihr was besser ist?
Behält man bei einem Revive den Killstreak?
Das wäre eigentlich cool.
Nämlich als Anreiz zum Reviven.
Also machen wir quasi On Deploy.
On Deploy resetten wir das.
So.
On Deploy.
Setz.
Nicht Add.
Das können wir uns sparen.
Setzten wir das auf 0.
Save.
Ok.
Cool.
Nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Das ist schön.
Ok.
Jetzt haben wir eine Möglichkeit Killstreaks zu zählen.
So.
Das hier ist der Killstreak.
Das hier ist der Killstreak für.
Wir machen das jetzt mal ganz rudimentär.
Wir sagen bei drei Killstreaks.
After Life Kills sind dann nutzlos.
Ja gut.
Ich glaube da können wir jetzt nicht drauf achten.
Da müssen wir irgendwie tracken können was passiert nachdem er abgelebt ist.
Nee.
After Life Kills sind nicht nutzlos.
Weil On Deploy wird das resettet.
On Deploy ist wenn er respawn.
Das heißt wenn der eine Granate wirft stirbt und die Granate killt was.
Dann zählt das trotzdem noch.
Vermute ich mal stark.
Ok.
Dann machen wir jetzt mal.
Der Oberpeitscher ist am Start.
Kann man diese Sachen irgendwie ausstellen?
Kann man irgendwie Notifications ausmachen oder so?
Benachrichtigungen.
Wo denn?
Da.
Benachrichtigungen.
Benachrichtigungen hier.
Nice easy.
Leak.
Bonkers.
Gut.
Also das ist unser Blackbird.
Gibt es Comments?
Comment wäre nicht schlecht.
Nee.
So eine Comment wäre auch ganz praktisch.
Dass ich da beischreiben könnte.
Das hier ist.
Kann man das irgendwie kommentieren oder so?
Was machst du da?
Ich versuche NOSHA TDR mit Killstreaks zu programmieren in Portal.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Set Variable auf Dings.
Wenn.
Ok.
Wir gucken jetzt, ob der Spieler 3 Kills hat.
Kannst du die 2 Rules beide on Kill nennen?
Nee.
Wahrscheinlich schon, aber das ist drüben nicht.
On Respawn nenne ich das mal.
On Deploy ist das bestimmt.
Das ist bestimmt.
Deploy ist garantiert so ein internes Frostbite Event Name.
so ein komisches bestimmt das ist bestimmt deploy ist garantiert so ein internes frostbite event name
noch eine sub-routine habe ich gesagt ich habe nicht gecheckt wie der kram funst
ich habe das hier versucht vorhin rein zu ziehen ein schimmer
ich habe keine ahnung wie man hier irgendwas verbindet miteinander
das macht einfach nix also was man anscheinend machen kann ist kreate subdomain hier irgendwie
das message und dann kann man das hier wahrscheinlich rein ziehen ok aber wo ziehe ich das dann hin ok
so jetzt ganz links auswählen ok das ist gut das ist gut ok ok dann ist dann ist nice also
dann passt es ja ok dann habe ich nichts gesagt dann ist das sinnvoll das habe ich nicht gecheckt
so rename das ist spot all players moment das spottet ja auch das eigene team seck das ist
ziemlich ziemlich pepega moment ich will nicht all players moment moment das ist das ist das
ist nicht nicht sonderlich nicht sonderlich schlau aber wir machen jetzt erstmal dass ich
kann das hier filtern ich muss ich get players ich muss get players auf und on team von event
player muss ich machen das wird das probieren wir gleich das probieren wir gleich aus
killstrix wie soll das gehen naja du merkst dir wann die leute was killen und wenn sie sterben
resettest du ihren kill count und wenn sie ein gewisse gewisse anzahl erreicht haben an kills
dann dann dann führt irgendwas aus das sind halt hardcoded kill streaks dann also sprich
bei drei kills geht automatisch der blackbird an wie man wie man selectable kill streaks machen
soll beziehungsweise die kill streaks player interacted auswählen kann keine ahnung
problem ist nur man muss sich merken ob die kill streaks ausgeführt wurde nee warum wenn
er der kann ja nur einmal drei kills haben pro leben wenn er stirbt das deckt nicht also hast
du zugriff auf den chat oh das ist eine gute idee wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich nicht chat
nein das das wäre gut wenn man zugriff auf den chat hat dann könnte man genau genau genau das
wäre nice aber das geht glaube ich nicht also es gibt es nix players was kann man hier machen
get inventory is inventory slot active vielleicht was kann was kann man da auswählen das da könnte
man schon was tricksen da könnte man schon was tricksen da könnte man zum beispiel machen wenn
die leute irgendwie auf auf man könnte man könnte das das vierte gadget locken man könnte sagen du
musst als viertes gadget keine ahnung xy mitnehmen und sobald er aufs vierte gadget
switch wird der kill streak ausgelöst irgendwie so das das könnte man glaube ich was was drehen mit
das müsste wahrscheinlich funktionieren ja ich gucke mal was gibt es denn sonst auch so user
interface custom messages nie player input gibt es aber nicht player input restriction was das
input restriction feier da kann man ihm verbieten irgendwas zu machen das das braucht man nicht
replace player inventory in event was was denn für eine inventor das sind die wo die gadgets
drin sind na hey das ist ja cool da könnte man zum beispiel hey das ist nice da könnte man zum
beispiel als fünfer kill streak dem typen granatwerfer geben oder sowas wobei das halt in
battlefield ziemlich sinnlos ist weil es gibt kaum was besseres als die mainwaffe aber das
würde funktionieren force revive du meinst dass der das könnte man das könnte man tatsächlich
machen force revive ist eine gute idee quasi ab zehn kills ab zehn kills kriegt er quasi
in leben geschenkt oder so da kann man da kann man viel zeug bauen gehe ich von aus so force man
down ist der typ geht down das natürlich resupply heal die damage das sind alles ganz gute sachen
die man dafür machen könnte skip teleport aber man kann den ach guck mal hier vector teleport
und soweit nach vorne und sowas oder man bekommt armor schieber 2 sowas da kann man da kann man
tatsächlich einiges cooles machen aber ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben wir müssen
erstmal so die so die basics dass es das überhaupt funktioniert ok aber chat chat geht leider nicht
viel damage ne chat geht leider nichts was gibt es hier track was track variable at rate was ah
man kann quasi so automatisch was hochzählen lassen das ist das ist keine ahnung wenn ich
das das könnte man zum beispiel benutzen so nach dem motto wenn du eine minute überlebst
kriegst du mehr leben oder irgendwie so was das ist ok ok wait wait until a board gameplay was
haben ansonsten redeploy time enable ok das ist eher so ein globales ding uns jetzt nicht so nicht
so toll general set team id kill spot target ansport das hatten wir schon array quick muffs
convenience remove from array index of array ok ich glaube jetzt habe ich so ungefähr ungefähr
mitbekommen was das so alles gibt also das heißt wir checken jetzt ob der typ drei kills hat wenn
er drei kills hat ich meine das ist natürlich vielleicht bisschen op 15 sekunden blackbird für
drei kills aber zum ausspringen reicht das man könnte auch anti camping zeugs einbauen anti camp
könnte man einbauen zum beispiel wenn du wenn player kein movement macht falls das falls das geht
dann kriegt er leben abgezogen was ist denn wenn man ewig auf drei kills bleibt gar nichts dann
gibt es dann kriegst du einmal 15 sekunden zehn sekunden uav und das war es das das das tritt nur
einmal auf hier ok also das if machen wir mal if equals mit hilfs hilfs gelb layer kills event
player also langsam so langsam blick ich halbwegs durch team id hinten kommt es zum vergleichen rein
number ist das nee wo war das hier literals number hat kein number so wenn der drei kills hat also
von der idee passt es ja auch wir starten achso wir bräuchten initial value das müssen wir hier
machen ein einmal initial für alle für alle spieler das auf null setzen denke ich mal oder
meint ihr der ist so schlau und startet bei null da wäre ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher
das müssen wir müssen einmal für alle spieler auf auf null setzt gibt es so was wie moment
gibt es so was wie spieler joint in server join game wobei und deployen die brauche
man nicht ist ja schwachsinn und die ploi ne passt schon ergibt keinen sinn was ich erzählt hab wir
haben ja und die ploi und die ploi setzt es ja schon auf null ja ja ne ne passt schon passt
also wenn wenn der kill count also wenn er drei kills gemacht hat moment der erste kill ist eins
der zweite kill ist denn das stimmt das stimmt das passt es dann auch nicht erst bei vier kills
als bei null anfängt ne ne das passt schon so das heißt jetzt kann ich diesen ganzen mist hier den
da auch ich doch jetzt eigentlich hier so weichern also das heißt wenn er drei kills gemacht hat
dann werden alle player gespottet aber das hier ist jetzt verkehrt das ist jetzt verkehrt ich
brauche nicht value in get all players ich muss get players filtern für alle für alle in seinem
team weinert dieser protein ja gleich gleich weil jetzt muss ich das hier filtern aber filter
oh nice hat sogar selbst hinzugefügt aber falsch rum hinzugefügt hat es get players muss vorne hin das
wird richtig messer pfeifert hier sollen das muss ich jetzt völlig alle kam gibt es so was
wie enemy so filter und den filter muss ich jetzt noch auf gegner team machen ach guck mal hier
steht sogar ein beispiel drin get players equals get team id team event event team passt doch event
event team proma das was anderes kann ich das von ongoing team event kontakt müsste eigentlich so
passen team equals current ach ne das ist der player equals oh gott jetzt wirds pfeifert jetzt
wirds pfeifert get ich muss ich muss ich muss get get team id machen werden dann die gegner
nicht für alle spieler aus dem eigenen team gespottet doch doch ok das das glaube ich
jetzt kann man das anders machen spot target trotz der target player nö das geht nur für alle du
kannst es nicht nur für dich spotten lassen ist dann fürs gesamte team ja gut was willst du machen
ne vielleicht ist ja der grund warum das in gott auch so ist wobei ist der blackbird fürs ganze
team gewesen oder nur für einen selbst glaube das fürs ganze team gewesen ich hab das meistens
für im free for all gespielt also filter array equals so also ok mal jetzt muss ich mal kurz in
mich gehen also für also für alle spieler die wir hier hat überprüfen jetzt ob current array
element team id get team id muss man hier machen also ob das team von dem spieler aus dem array
gleich get team id für dem event ist ok so das heißt nicht equals wir brauchen nicht
equals wir brauchen wir brauchen dings not not equals not equal to brauma so gut also
der der holt mir jetzt die spieler raus die nicht im eigenen team sind und spottet die
ach nee count muss ich da jetzt noch davor machen ne count alter was ding da blickst
ja nimmer durch das ist ja riesen fetter ok count off und jetzt
jaja in spot target
so passt das jetzt ich blick ich mich das ist mehr ist mehr ist mir zu hoch value in
array ja das müsste eigentlich passen war feifett alter richtig feifett ok perfekt
so und das ganze jetzt in die subroutine rein das kann weg das brau man nicht mehr das kann
auch aus subroutine spott all players spott all players ist ja auch verkehrt das ist spott
all enemies spott all enemies spott all enemies das kann ich jetzt irgendwie hier irgendwie
hier hin legen und dann kann ich sagen hier unten spott all enemies ok dann ist es ein
bisschen bisschen übersichtlicher der ganze krempel
das ist cancer man warum warum kann ich nicht einfach eine stecknormale programmier sprache
dafür also das bedeutet wenn einer drei kills gemacht hat dann kriegt er dann kriegt das
wird das gegner team geheiligt ok das probieren jetzt gleich aus das probieren gleich aus
und er kriegt es gibt ne message es gibt ne message es gibt ne message gg eats war drei
kills weil dann alle code copy pasten würden ja gut machen sie doch auch so auch schon
die alten battlefield titel boten die möglichkeit ja du konntest beim server konntest ja kommt
du konntest sogar dotnet erweiterung machen bei diesem ganzen procon zeug damals
muss noch get player kills ersetzen
warum wo was wie jetzt völlig krank jetzt komme ich nicht mit wo muss ich was ersetzen
get player kills du meinst hier unten oder was
jetzt weiß ich nicht was ihr meint wo muss ich was machen
willst du nicht die globalen kills sondern die kill streak
stimmt das will ich nicht das ist richtig ich will das da haben
hier vor player das will ich haben genau richtig und dass wir sehen dass alles funktionierend
schreiben wir alle 30 sekunden keck wie größer 0w um rein für sechs sekunden event player
so moment hier kann man auch den name hier den name reinschreiben
da wird doch eben irgendwas wie string interpolation funktioniert oder hier schweifte klammern
auch guck mal auto kommt naja nicht wirklich autocomplete hilfe anzeigen ok nice
ja wunderbar gut speichern wir das mal ich hoffe ich darf jetzt ein
game mit bots erstellen dass ich drei bots killen kann und dann sollte ich die anzeige
bekommen gg eats informatikor und alle alle gegner sollten gespottet werden
schauen wir mal schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert vielen bin ich mal gespannt
was machst du da genau das ist der logik oder wie heißt das ding rules editor aus
battle field 2042 da kann man eigene spielmodi erstellen wenn auch mit einer äußerst umständlichen
wie heißt es so visuellen things zusammen klick programmier umgebung aber immerhin
kann man ja mal ausprobieren for each wäre sehr nice und for each ich meine warum brauche
ich eine globale variabel für eine vorschleife und dann aus dem index warum kann ich nicht
einfach ein for each machen das wäre schon äußerst praktisch so portal host host cute
tdm aus ich darf direkt hausten klapp klapp klapper klapper klapper klaus
ich habe gesehen irgendjemand im discord bei mir hat ein wollte glaube ich in den
pisen oder javascript zu portal compiler bauen weil unter der haube ist portal xml und er
hat sich überlegt können wir das nicht irgendwie automatisch generieren ja unter der haube
ist xml monarch s irgendwie hat man sich gedacht es passt schon nein nein nein so alt so alt
so haben wir bots am start keine bots moment ist ein gegner da ist der muss jetzt bashen
lassen von mir das jetzt drei ihr müsst euch jetzt von mir bashen dass ich drei kills machen
kann boah alter der sound von bettel viel man lasst euch von mir best ich brauche drei
kills dahinten ist er geile zitrone man riecht spockers das ist best geile zidrone wo geht
hier was ein kill noch um zu gucken ob es funktioniert funktioniert nicht es funktioniert
nicht warum nicht was ist falsch und die anzeige oben keck wie größer null wie funktioniert
auch nicht
es ding hat auch kein debug oder so
kann man das eigentlich ändern während man während man auf dem server drauf ist nee oder
ich habe nur ein gegner und das doch kein problem
ob es geruckelt hat man jetzt hat er sich dahingelegt
nee das bringt nichts ok aber das wechsel warum kommt noch nicht mal die message vielleicht
wegen dem ganzen zeug hier drum herum kann das sein dass er das nicht mag
also zumindest das sollte eigentlich kommen
da ist irgendwas kaputt da ist doch ein get players wo muss mir schon sagen wo ich blick
hier nicht mehr durch also set also condition set variable
so wir enden eins ich werde garantiert nicht viele modi selbst entwickeln
ach hier ist noch eins das ist jetzt einfach nur zum ausprobieren set variable also aber
zumindest inne das hier müsste kommen display notification keck wie größer null wie zumindest
das müsste eigentlich kommen
probieren wir es noch mal aus wir machen jetzt einmal noch mal was ich mache bots ich mache
wirklich mal bots rein
wo war denn das jetzt ai vielleicht darf ich dann was erstellen wenn ich pvp
kann aber auch sein dass das aus ist wie gesagt wegen portal host
die leute hier am start sind ok takedown host ich nenne es mal zwei
nee das geht und jetzt sollten sie aber bot sein
jetzt habe ich habe ich gespeichert
wait ist außerhalb der loop moment moment moment
das kommt einmalig und dann nie wieder
big brain time hier
alles klar
aber trotzdem das andere hat nicht funktioniert das hätte funktionieren sollen
portal host
ja takedown weg damit host qtdm 3
jetzt geht das wenigstens auch
das ist google blocky moment
das google blocky
na geil
spot all players war leer
nee die condition vielleicht vielleicht muss da auch eine condition rein dass es funktioniert
vielleicht klappt das mit der subroutine nicht
das könnte sein aber das hier sollte eigentlich funktionieren
display display notification gg eats event player
du bist für ever in der wildschleife nee das sind unterschiedliche events das kann
eigentlich nicht sein
schauen wir mal
ich mache das mal runter auf ein kill
das war gar kein bot der mich gekillt hat
oder wollte mich einer retten ich habe mich gekillt so specialist hier
das ist deutlich verwirrende als normaler code
ok einfach drei kills machen und gucken ob es funktioniert
das ding ist krass das wackelt ja viel mehr als die m16
imagine killed by bot
die bots habe ich die links auf beginner gestellt weil die drei bots killen man
moment die nachricht ist da oh leute ich will gucken ob ich drei bots killen kann ich mach
gleich passwort rein
ja die nachricht kommt die nachricht ist da aber 3 3 kills muss ich kriegen
sind aber es kann also einfach 3 kills zu kriegen die server message funktioniert
einer noch einer noch
das funktioniert einfach nicht das funktioniert nicht
die message kommt nicht die werden nicht gespottet
es müsste oben eine message kommen die sind rot wahrscheinlich weil die mein team
spottet oder so ja stimmt die sind gespottet weil die leute die spotten nicht
weil irgendwie was passiert
das funktioniert nicht die message kommt nicht wegen spam protection wenn spam protection
wäre dann müsste die message jetzt jetzt ja auch nicht laufen kommen da oben
guck die sind immer so gespottet und das ist viel länger als 15 sekunden
ne das funktioniert nicht
ok dann gehen wir mal raus lief game
so dann müssen wir dann müssen wir eigentlich uns jetzt brauchen wir irgendwie eine debug
ausgabe warum es nicht funktioniert wie machen wir das jetzt am besten
gg es ist im harassment filter ohne scheiß das könnte tatsächlich so sein
0w event player wir machen einfach so jetzt mal ich trau denen alles zu ich ohne scheiß
ich trau denen wirklich alles zu so spot enemies machen wir hier weg
so also guck mal lass mal überlegen set variable player variable für den player kills
also condition true ja player earned kill alles klar
muss ich das raus machen dass das jedes mal aufgerufen wird ich mach das mal ich mach
das mal raus
wir machen notification für kill so es sollte 0w kommen
1 2 3 irgendwas ich brauche irgendwas zum ausgabe
ich sollte jetzt bei jedem kill den ich mache sollte ich 0w als message bekommen und bei
3 kills müsste ich dann 1 2 3 bekommen als message
ich meine von der logik her ist dann guck mal also ich deploye so ich deploye ich setz
die variable kills auf 0 alles klar
so dann mach ich ein kill dann mach ich ein kill dann setze ich
die variable kills ist es die richtige reinfolge variable any type
dann setze ich die variable kills für den player und sag ok adde 1 zur variable und
speichert das ist doch eigentlich stimmen get variable könnte ich ausgeben ja mach
ich auch
f equals variable player count event player 3 das ist also so simpel das muss eigentlich
funktionieren
mach ich das denn richtig help event player genau so und da geben wir jetzt hier die get
variable aus
also ich sollte jetzt eigentlich jeden kill angezeigt bekommen 0w und dann mein mal was
mal umgedreht oh nein btf was jetzt alter ich möchte das lösen kann ich das lösen
jetzt schreckt wir rechnen eins hoch und geben es dann aus
muss da nix in die condition das werden wir jetzt gleich sehen das werden wir jetzt gleich
sehen host password ja ja
geht es vielleicht einfach nicht privat
das sieht nicht aus wie scratches google blocky
oh guck mal da kann man die server ziemlich überlastet ein bisschen wahrscheinlich er
geht ja nicht wirklich überlastet aber diesen anfrageserver könnte man wahrscheinlich
zuspammen und fast schon fast schon dedosten wenn man das automatisiert ich hab jetzt ich
hab jetzt da ein paar mal geklickt und es cute anscheinend
vielleicht muss die variablen mit null initialisieren mache ich ja guck mal mache ich ja ich sag
on respawn set auf null vielleicht muss ich ja auch die condition raussichteln jetzt ja
global quota exceeded ist gut 0w ja das ist ja dumm das kann man nicht mal richtig ausprobieren
so das ist vielleicht ein bug muss ich denn so muss ich das spiel neu starten mal ausprobieren
so also jetzt kann ja eigentlich nichts jetzt muss es muss auf jeden fall eine message kommen
was könnte der für schmerzen haben die server sind gibt zu wenige gibt zu wenig
auf connecte dich
ok das kann man vergessen ich meine überlegt euch mal wir müssten bei jedem test da viertel
stunde warten
die deployment ist beim das ist nicht hier und muss sich das eigentlich nennen
das muss schon funktionieren
ich meine ich konnte eben den server mit bots erstellen das das hat definitiv funktioniert
also daran wird es nicht liegen
das muss schon das muss schon so funktionieren das ist die einzige ist ja vielleicht teilen
sich alle spieler eine variablen ne das kann nicht sein guck mal player ne ne ne ne ne
das glaube ich nicht event player nee das ist das ist das ist schon pro eine variablen
pro spieler hast du wieder bots an ja aber es ging ja eben mit bots
das können wir vergessen man kann ich kann bots noch mal ausmachen
aber ich meine wir hatten eben schon mal ein game
wir hatten eben schon mal ein game mit bots und das hat funktioniert also das kann eigentlich
nicht sein jetzt probiere aus und mach erst mal keine
kiste schaue ob es wirklich die gegner automatisch spottet oder nicht das ist auch egal ob das
spottet oder nicht die message kommt ja noch nicht mal wenn die message nicht kommt dann
dann funktioniert ja die ganze logik nicht
ok leute ich hatte die bots drin lassen sollen weil jetzt muss ich euch noch mal
wie ist das denn jetzt cute kdm 3 oder irgendwie so was
das funst das wird das weiß ich dass es funst keck wie größer lull weh was da alle 15 sekunden
kommt vielleicht hängt die message vielleicht können es nicht zu viele messages sein
auf also mich rein lass mich rein
so das server heißt sieht man das irgendwie kann man irgendwie nachgucken wie das server
heißt admin cute tdm einfach nur ok
leute ich muss mal wieder zwei leute von euch killen redeploy könnte auch redeploy den kram
auch ausgeben
also jetzt reicht ja ein kill sogar um zum ausprobieren ob wenigstens die variable gesetzt
wird
da ist einer ok kam eins gerade habe ich das hier auch drin
moment da kam eins was eins ja gut der hat es jetzt gespeichert eins ok
mal gucken ob das jetzt ja vielleicht ist das zählt dass ich mich selbst gekillt habe
das ist ein ein ein kill hier da oben ist einer nicht wegrennen
aus irgendwelchen gründen ist er aber gespottet
zwei ok einer noch einer noch und dann sollte er eigentlich ausgeben
dann sollte er eigentlich ausgeben display 1 2 3 bei 3 kills
das sieht man jetzt nicht
hey funktioniert doch alles ok dann ist das doch dann lag das an diesen conditions die
irgendwie rumgesponnen haben
also da können wir jetzt ausgeben kills
dire streak
so und die display notification die soll ja eigentlich auch nur an den event player
kann man das hier filtern
moment display hier nur an den event player und das hier soll auch nur an mich wenn ich
drei kills gemacht habe
dreier streak
ok also das das funktioniert ja soweit und jetzt kann ich die subroutine rein machen
und dann weiß jemand nicht wo der unterschied ist zu vorher
wisst ihr was gut wäre wenn ich es refreshen könnte
restart map geht das vielleicht wenn ich den next map mache
du kannst doch bei der condition sagen ob selbst ja aber das macht macht nicht kaputt
ich hoffe das reloaded wir müssen mal ausprobieren ob es reloaded wir können das ausprobieren
indem wir die meldung ändern jetzt ist nämlich 0w größer keqw was ja eigentlich auch richtig
ist
mal gucken ob man reloaden kann
der unterschied ist keine conditions genau
also man das ne das ist ne ne ist richtig richtig muss noch mal neu next map aber wahrscheinlich
muss ich das neu erstellen dass es funktioniert
alter game warum lädst du so lang
ok admin experience custom banlist
broadcast message restart map take down
mal gucken ob das reload bei next map aber wahrscheinlich nicht ich muss den server
neu machen gehe ich von aus ich glaube der lädt es nur einmalig
sehen wir gleich und es müsste 0w größer keqw drinstehen
was steht bei den error logs da müsste ich mal gucken
schauen wir gleich ich mach noch mal neu auf geht ja leider nicht anders ne
take down confirm host new tdm
alter ah nice man muss man muss einfach noch genug
genug spammen dann dann geht das
ja warten wir mal was bei error messages steht
ok jetzt ist auch 0w keqw was auch die richtige variante ist
weil ehrlich gesagt ist das ein deutlich besseres lach emote als das
aber keqw ist in der heutigen zeit einfach meta
bots ich weiß ich hatte ich jetzt bots angeschaltet noch
sehen wir gleich
müssen wir wieder warten bis einer joint zum glück heißt die map ja auch immer gleich
einfach cute tdm suchen
ja zusammengeschrieben
und steht jetzt was von eins um
das ist das ist keine global message mit den kills die kriegt nur ich
kills achtung kills zwei hills zwei nice
das ist nicht bei viel drei das ist well viel drei in bettel viel 20 42 so gleich sollte
kills drei kommen dann sollte auch da stehen dreier streak und er sollte die gegner
highlighten haben wir mehr als zwei gegner ich glaube schon
kills drei
und
dreier streak
aber das highlighten funktioniert nicht
ok die kill streak sache funktioniert aber das highlighten funktioniert nicht
eigentlich sollte die gegner spotten jetzt
ja gut
ist natürlich doof
ich meine ich will nicht alles botten lassen das wäre ziemlich pepega
waren die beim highlight noch im spawnmenü weiß ich probiere mal aus ob der kram redeploy
kills vier wie mein eigener kill zu meinen kill streaks zählt keck weight
hallo respawn please
pass auf die spielen jetzt voll hier um ihr leben wahrscheinlich da ich kann keine dreier
kills mehr hinkriegen
also ich glaube die globale message können wir raus machen die die bringt schon mal nix
die sound engine ist so schlecht
du hörst du hörst hier so viel und es ist nichts da
ja gut da krieg ich jetzt keine gescheiten dreier kills oh jetzt können wir gleich gucken
ob das
zwei kills ok nice wenn du revive wirst
ey das highlighten funst guck mal
das funst alles ist alles gut
ha ha pepega hat alle
weg pepega es funktioniert alles guck mal die gegner sind gehighlightet für 14 sekunden
hallo kann man nicht durch diesen komischen sound schießen
cool cool ich bin ich bin ich bin begeistert
ich bin begeistert das funktioniert
ok nice dann dann bauen wir mal weiter was ist denn noch ein guter kill streak
es gibt keine bullet penetration ja ok lief ich lasse den server drauf da könnt ihr wenn
ihr irgendwie noch euch ein bisschen killen wollt könnt ihr machen aber wenn ich den
nächsten test mache mach ich ihn weg ok das funktioniert dann brauchen wir jetzt da brauchen
wir jetzt noch eine ordentliche ordentliche anzeige dreier streak starte ulv wir machen
das mal auf deutsch so richtig wie die wie die letzten karten
wir können es auch immer triple streak streak launch ulv wir schreiben ulv active ulv active
so alles klar ich habe es jetzt auch gecheckt warum das nicht funktioniert das ist eigentlich
richtig gut das ist viel besser als ich mir das gedacht habe es werden nur lebende gegner
gehighlightet also sprich das ist kein blackbird 14 sekunden das ist quasi ein 10 sekündiger
uav pulse und wenn du stirbst bist du weg und wirst nicht mehr angezeigt das ist für
einen dreier kill streak eigentlich gar nicht so doof weil überlegt euch mal zehn sekunden
blackbird für drei kills wäre vielleicht ein bisschen op ulv inbound
dena streak ammo refill ja das finde ich gut die können wir auch besser testen als den
habe ich jetzt bots an ich mache jetzt noch mal bots an da kann ich nämlich trotzdem
einfacher testen hier bots 10 stück pvp ai ist gut dann kann dann darf nur ich was was
können die pv ai heißt die schießt nicht zurück ja sehr gut sehr gut perfekt ok also
was können was können wir noch für was können wir noch für kill streaks machen also dreier
dreier kill streaks ist sport sport all enemies bei zweckstatt aber wird jetzt für das ganze
team gespotten nur für den das aus für alle das ist ein uav pulse fürs gesamte team allerdings
nicht fürs gegner team allerdings ein dreier kill streak dürfte eigentlich fast permanent
uav irgendwie oben sein das heißt es ist eigentlich zu op das müsste man theoretisch noch ein
bisschen ein bisschen switchen ja aber es geht jetzt ja auch nicht darum das super balance
überhaupt zu zu basteln ja wisst ihr was wir machen sollten der ranger hund das ist
eine gute idee für 10er killstück richtig gut das das können wir noch verfeinern alles
ranger hund streak das aber bf3 da gibt es den ranger hund streak glaube nicht schauen
wir mal schauen probieren probieren aus also wir sollten diese messages mit den kills warum
kann man das nicht man sollte das man sollte das nur als letztes anzeigen wenn sonst nichts
angezeigt wurde also brauche man den els if els if äh äh moment condition if oh das
ist ja dumm äh wie kann ich den els machen
eh ne das ist das ist das ist starship ne wie heißt das conditional ding pump operator
ne needuki das wollen wir nicht zahlrad im if statement aha okay ach so ah das das das
das ist aber broken oder ist das kaputt ich glaube das geht nicht oder wie funktioniert
das ich glaube was fack achso so ok da müssen wir das nämlich nach unten machen der höchste
killstreak muss natürlich oben stehen weil sonst funktioniert das ganze natürlich nicht
so also das ist der 3er killstreak jetzt machen wir als nächstes machen wir einen 5er killstreak
was haben wir für einen 5er killstreak zur auswahl ammo ja ammo 5er killstreak ist für
ammo oder 5er killstreak ist für ammo oder eigentlich ohne scheiß eigentlich können
wir ammo bei 4 machen ammo bringt doch keinen um ammo machen wir in 4er da gibt es wenigstens
auch immer immer was refill set inventory get inventory ammo moment wie macht man das
jetzt player wie wie füllt man die die munition auf resupply resupply loadout crate ok da
bin ich jetzt mal gespannt wieder was das da macht resupply bei 4 kills resupply event
und hier was resupply type resupply type massive big brain ammo box ammo crate wie darf ich
mir das vorstellen spawn dann auf dem boden ammo box was ich eigentlich richtig cool finden
würde weil dann hätte das gesamte team was von loadout crate what ammo box wisst ihr
was wir machen wir machen einfach alles und gucken was passiert wir lassen ihn einfach
komplett resupply beim ersten kill schon beim das aber falsch rum wir machen vier ich habe
ja bots an ich habe ja bots an vier bots werde ich ja noch hinkriegen oder eine message
brauchen wir noch ja genau message hast ja recht ja hier restrict ammo refill nice ey
das macht spaß ohne scheiß soll ich euch was sagen real talk ich habe mehr spaß daran
gerade als ein battlefield zu spielen host think down weg damit host
der player bekommt das in sein inventar man hat in battlefield kein inventar man hat gadgets
aber man hat kein inventar wie welches inventar man hat man hat er kein inventar ich habe
zumindest noch nicht gedrückt sagt sagt nicht wenn man hat man hat ein inventar in in portal
irgendwie wenn der server noch ein bisschen schneller laden würde wir auch bock ja aber
man hat ja eine ammo box wenn man die hinstellen muss aber ich habe ja keine ammo box aus ich
muss mal gucken wie das ist bin ich bin echt gespannt ok also wo sind die bots die bots
schießen jetzt übrigens nicht zurück also die bots sollten eigentlich nicht zurückschießen
weil ich habe die auf pve gestellt lull kills 1 hier konnte man übrigens battlefield 3
glaube ich nicht hoch die schießen auf mich kills 2 slider slider slider imagine killed
bei bot wo ist man hier ne das war jetzt drei oder ne vier moment hat es jetzt hat es jetzt
irgendwas gemacht wurde ich wieder bleibt habt ihr geguckt ich habe gar nicht gecheckt
ob ich wieder bleibt wurde wurde ich wieder bleibt also ist meine wurde ich wurde noch
gerätzt ne ne ne ne redeploy ich habe es nicht geguckt wurde ich jetzt wieder bleibt
oder nicht ja fünf kills lull von wegen habe ich selbst gekillt nee nee da hätte ich 155
haben müssen bei resupply ich werfe jetzt keine ich werfe jetzt keine medipacks weil
es kann sein dass es geplockt war dadurch imagine imagine killed by bot und imagine
nicht treffen lass mich spawnen so guck mal hier sind sie alle eins oh monka zu viele bots
die hinten ja sogar was ok hammer hammer hammer streaks uav uav ok uav habe ich schon viel
gemacht ne ne noch nicht ok ich sehe nix man und jetzt ich wurde resupplied guck mal hat
funktioniert habt ihr es gesehen ist auf 155 hoch ich wurde resupplied nice ich weiß zwar
ich weiß zwar nicht genau wie und warum aber es hat funktioniert
ich habe jetzt 155 guck mal es hat funktioniert man sieht es nicht wegen dem chat ah ja moment
chat chat ich schiebe euch mal ganz kurz weg sodass ihr was seht so
so die frage ist ob wir resupplied werden
sag mal warum trifft das denn nix
zwei kills ok ich muss dieses lullweg weg machen das ist richtig dumm ok uav jetzt
soll die uav kommen sind die jetzt alle highlighted weiß ich nicht wahrscheinlich oder ich denke
schon dass das funktioniert so und jetzt soll ich resupplied wenn ich hab 83 guck mal hier
83 jetzt sollte ich gleich 155 wieder haben wenn das funst mit resupplied gegner please
oder nice nice nice huge huge res habt ihr den slowdown gesehen meine güle es hat einfach
auf 20 fps runter auf 20 fps runter geruckelt kommen hier schon wieder gerätzt por gass
nice aber ich hab nur ich hab nur ein hp ok jetzt noch mal eine chance also teammates
bekommen uav und ich bekomme die spots auch ok nice so sollte das eigentlich auch sein
aber kann es sein dass die bots mittlerweile spiele ersetzt wurden so resupplied geht guck
mal unten 155 155 hat funktioniert ok der resupplied funktioniert auch sehr schön sehr schön
was ich nicht so ganz check ist nice ok ich gebe da raus funktioniert was ich nicht so
ganz check ist warum also was ist der unterschied hier dazwischen
vielleicht jeder vielleicht ist der unterschied wie viel resupplied wird wie sind die bots
naja nichts besonderes das ist bestimmt wie viel wie viel man bekommt aber wenn ich das
so mache wird man komplett aufgefüllt ich lasse es einfach so ich lasse es einfach so
man kriegt jetzt einfach alles bäm aber ich glaube loadout create können wir raus machen
ok jetzt ist die frage kann ich so einen komischen hund spawnen lassen bei sagen wir mal irgendwie
sechs kills aber wenn ich bei sechs kills den hund spawnen lassen dann campen alle wie
verrückt hp boost kill streak ich weiß nicht das finde ich immer problematisch dann hältst
du mehr aus und die gegner kann ich nicht richtig killen aber wir gucken mal ob man
irgendwie player was man was man den player geben kann schaffst du überhaupt sechs kills
in der wahrscheinlich nicht dem spiel nicht viel damage skip skip man down was macht das
tage platter skip manner ach so damit man direkt rieb deployed set player soldier set
the tage player solcher using a provide player solcher ach so ich kann jetzt hier nicht auswählen
du wechselst zu bad company zwei solcher zwischendurch ok das funktioniert deal damage heal resupply
force revive ok hier kann man kann man zum heilen sets inventory was ne ne resupply ist
viel besser weil das berücksichtigt auch wie viel money man haben kann und sowas
set inventory switch switch inventory was macht das ach so das ist das ist näher das
ist ja blödsinnig replace inventory item if the tage player a new inventory item inventory
ach so ok erfüllt man kann kann man granaten und sowas auffüllen
inventory kann man den könnte man den leuten dort irgendwas irgendwas sinnvolles geben
irgendwie secondary weapon aber da gibt es nichts gescheites ja das ist glaube ich ein
pack mit das teammates rot markiert werden spot also die teammates werden aus irgendwelchen
gründen mit gespottet wenn gegner ein dreier streak hat oder so glaube da kann man nichts
kann man nichts machen ich ich spotte nur die nur die enemies aber anscheinend werden
die auch rot wenn sie gespottet werden vom gegner keine ahnung ja man kann 128 spiele
einstellen ja was gibt es denn was können wir jetzt noch was können wir jetzt noch
cooles machen also nuke lasse ich jetzt erst mal raus kann man so einen hund spawnen das
interessiert mich tatsächlich das aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht wie ehrlich gesagt spawn
deploy also du hast ja bei battlefield 2042 hast ja dieses dieses kann man kann man fahrzeuge
spawn wahrscheinlich nicht was ist das enable vo messaging was ist das ist das voice chat
was ist denn vo messaging die laufgeschwindigkeit ich glaube die kann man anpassen vielleicht
aber auch nur in dem spiel modus selbst logic gameplay was kann man denn machen respawn
time enable all player deploy game mode game score ach die dialoge der spot ne das hatten
wir schon alles player input restriction also man kann auch kein fahrzeug oder so spawnen
lassen das funktioniert nicht das ist dann doch bisschen user interface ja es ist doch
schon relativ beschränkt was man machen kann und fällt jetzt da gar nicht mehr so viel
ein gang müsste tatsächlich relativ easy zu machen sein ein gang guckst du on kill du
tracks welche positionen und dann guckst du nach der position wechselst die waffe das
gang müsste tatsächlich relativ einfach machen sein zu machen sein also das hier ist ja das
das eigentlich entscheidende was man machen kann gameplay und player so und ich sehe da
nichts wie man irgendwie drohnen oder so spawnen lassen könnte und ich sehe auch nicht wie
man irgendwie fahrzeuge oder so spawnen könnte ich kann eigene variablen setzen ja aber das
bringt uns jetzt ja nix ja hat man hat noch nie mal eine coole idee für irgendwie den
sechser kill streak oder so man spotten alle für 15 sekunden ok smoke gibt es gibt es
ja gibt es ja nicht mehr als einen granaten typ kann man ja auch nicht haben man könnte
zum beispiel ich meine es gibt was geht alles das kann ich jetzt nicht so einfach ich meine
man könnte ja sagen zum beispiel man verbietet freqs und bekommt bei sechs irgendwie sechser
stree irgendwie zwei freqs oder irgendwie sowas aber das ist auch nicht so auch nicht
so das sind panzer platte gibt es gibt es nicht zumindest nicht so aus gibt ammo open gadget
inventory slot inventory inventory throwables gucken wir mal wir gucken einfach mal inventory
wo steht denn das hier player inventory ich weiß gar nicht wo das vor das überhaupt
drunter steht hier selection lists actions player inventory slot kann es mal bitte aufbleiben
hier primary weapons open gadgets ich meine du kannst das gadget du kannst du kannst
einem eine rpg geben oder so du kannst quasi eine medic irgendwie rpg geben aber es geht
nur mit open gadgets inventory das ist eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich wenig was man da machen
kann inventory primary weapons nahkampfwaffen open gadgets throwables secondaries character
specialization oder sowas bf3 ja das geht ja nur wenn es das geht ja nur wenn es das
spielmodus auf bf3 gestellt ist ich mein man könnte jemanden ja aber dann nimmt man
den medic zum beispiel seine seine healbox weg für so ein uav ding ne es ist nicht abhängig
vom spiel weil es müsste in es müsste ja hier hier kann man 2042 ausrüsten aber mir
fällt jetzt hier nichts ein was da als spawn von einem hund gelten würde du kannst hier
zwar auswählen 2042 und dann kannst du sagen century gun sonst was aber du kannst nicht
irgendwie den hovercraft oder so spawnen lassen oder den hund der hund ist ja ein drop down
also ist er die kantor so ein airdrop natürlich blöd leute ich muss mal ganz kurz ganz kurz
afk gleich wieder da und ich muss den chat fällt mir gerade ein ich muss den chat noch
mal rüberschieben hallo was ist das ok so ok leute ich bin mal kurz auf klo da
so ich bin wieder da wie kommt ihr eigentlich darauf dass es überhaupt ein kix ist ich
dachte es ist keck s quasi der vorgänger von keck weh jetzt ne ich finde ich dass das
weh getan hat ich finde also wenn ihr mal richtig wenn ihr mal richtig pains jam wissen
wollt was weh tut das ist das ist so schlecht es gibt einen es gibt einen steckdosen hersteller
da heißt gosund und ich dachte der nennt sich nach corona in gesund um das ist das ist das
ist richtiger pains champions ok wo sind verstehen geblieben so wo sind verstehen geblieben also
ja wir brauchen noch irgendeinen kill streak der sich damit umsetzen lässt immer ein schön
und gut dass man jwies bekommt dass man ammo refill bekommt aber man kann ja sonst nicht
wirklich was machen also das ist das ist doch schon sag mal relativ beschränkt ne also was
man machen könnte ist was ich was ich ganz cool finde man könnte noch geheilt werden
bei bei dem vierer kill streak das finde ich tatsächlich nicht schlecht hier nicht max
er hiel auf was macht man da hiel setze amount of health gained in an instant for the target
player apply by by healer player ne ne man konnte doch medipack resupply machen aber
doch eben gesehen player medipack resupply medgadget hier medgadget types event player
medgadget ne medgadget type geheilt bei medikit
das krieg jetzt wirst du nämlich voll resupply und folge heilt beim vierten kill was ist
man dauernd dass du direkt respawnst ohne wenn dauernd zu gehen was wahrscheinlich bei
den anderen darauf rausläuft dass du nicht rewifed werden kann sondern instant respawnst
oder so ab zehn kill stirbt man keine tryhards top idee mir also mir fällt jetzt wirklich
nichts ein die sachen die ich mir hier gedacht habe die gehen alle nicht habe man könnte
beispielsweise smoke werfen oder so aber das das das das funktioniert nicht ja du kannst
hier du hast zwar ganz viel aber es gibt kaum was was was wektors annimmt wo man etwas
mal das einzige was es gibt ist teleport und teleport macht jetzt in dem fall keinen sinn
wo steht dann teleport überhaupt drin und da unter was steht dann teleport hier player
aber gut ich glaube das wollen die noch ein bisschen erweitern weil es hätte keinen sinn
diese ganzen vector types zu machen für nichts im endeffekt das ist fürs aktuelle leben
du wirst einmalig geheilt und das war es bei bei vier kills komm einen gescheiten kill
street muss uns doch noch einfallen den man hiermit umsetzen kann
nee quatsch ich will nicht mehr als max health haben 100 health ist gut sonst hast du das
problem dass ich keiner gescheit killen kann
mini tron das problem ist das kannst du nicht umsetzen
run speed kannst du auch nicht ändern ich glaube du kannst den run speed den run speed
kannst du hier ändern irgendwo bei den settings aber ich glaube man kann nicht hier den run
speed ändern
default gamemode scoring enable default gamemode win condition
set gamemode time limit set gamemode target score nee kannst du nicht machen
kannst du nicht machen das wäre cool das würde ich sofort machen zweimal run speed
aber kannst du nicht also zumindest
es gibt closest player 2 ja aber ich wüsste nicht wie man
ach da könnte man das filtern tatsächlich
das ist eigentlich auch eine coole idee dass man die leute quasi nicht komplett highlight
ist sondern nur die in der nähe sind weil aktuell machen wir so wir highlighten schon
alle gegner bei bei einem dreier kill streak allerdings für zehn sekunden nur einmal
pro leben man kann den spieler ammo auch wieder
wegnehmen ja ja gut klar können sie nuken aber das
ist jetzt erst mal so so so funny ding was man noch einbauen kann aber was was könnte
man noch machen also im dreier vierer fünfer kill streak würde ich machen das ist ja alles
relativ eigentlich müsste man das switchen bei fünf gibt es den spot und bei bei drei
und vier gibt es refill und sowas kann man vielleicht spieler mit streaks anzeigen lassen
auf der map für gegner ja das geht
nee bloß zehn hells ist blöd das ist das ist sowas mag ich nicht
wobei man das jetzt machen könnte einfach nur damit halt geht ja also man könnte also
man kann man kann spieler anzeigen lassen ja das funktioniert kann sie einfach sagen
spot sport und an event player und dann ist er gespottet für alle ich meine das könnte
man machen das könnte man eigentlich ist die idee gar nicht so schlecht man könnte sagen
bei fünf bei fünf kills bekommt der bekommt das spieler 200 prozent leben wird aber permanent
angezeigt für immer bis er stirbt das brauchen wir mal ein das interessiert mich jetzt einfach
funktioniert als als if das haben es geprägt von ks oje oje
moment als if als if drei muss man das leider alles umhängen ok passt passt
wieder so if if fünf hells set player max hells ja das kann man tatsächlich machen
event player 200 literals 200 250 250 und er wird gespottet er wird gespottet für alle
und für immer spott event player für fünf minuten und jetzt bauen wir hier noch ans
spott am tot wenn man wenn man tot ist ans spott ist es eben ein bisschen verschoben hier das
hier alles das weg ok wenn man stirbt ans spott event player ja es gibt keine suppression
in battlefield 3 hier gibt keine suppression in 2042 remake probieren wir mal aus ob das
funktioniert mal kurz bots einstellen kurz was ist der was ist pvp pvp ja beginner easy
ist es eben leute drauf lull sorry rip oh was jetzt aus oh nee nicht schon wieder please
jetzt ist sogar unknown error am start vorbei einmal müssen wir den selber noch aufkriegen
gut tdm 69 69 ist bestimmt blacklist darf man bestimmt nicht aufmachen ich klicke jetzt
einfach so lange bis es funktioniert das hausten weil zu viele leute kratzer das hausten
gerade zu viele leute server ok bei fünf kills sollte ich jetzt ich kann jetzt mal eine
sache gerade machen was ich ja die ganze zeit hätte machen sollen jetzt die mouse sensitivity
ein bisschen runter stellen ich zeige euch noch mal kurz was was ich auch nervig finde
bei der waffen bei der attachment auswahl oder um zu sagen was das muss weg lull wie
größer keck weder drehst ja durch wenn es permanent angezeigt wird zack dass das muss
das muss rules editor kann man die sachen nicht einfach deaktivieren perfekt
was ich bei der waffen auswahl auch sehr pence jumping finde ist wenn du hier zum
beispiel das das visier ändern willst du musstest du musstest quasi hier aus switchen
das ist ganz ganz komisch irgendwie wo ist denn hier kodra wo ist das kodra visier man
gibt gibt es kein gibt es kein kodra visier das ist ja doch da ist es doch genau wenn
man das wenn man das switchen will dann ist das das ist wirklich endet position da muss
man wieder und es ist wir es ist wirklich komisch ganz ganz komisch
warum kann man nicht hier direkt drauf klicken warum muss ich immer erst hier anklicken
finde ich doch schon ziemlich ein ziemlich großer pence champ
oh wie viele bots mann guck mal das kann man hier auch wechseln ok kills eins so fünf
fünf fünf kills musch da nicht das kodra visier ist eh nicht sichtbar wirklich warum
warum nicht das muss ich ausprobieren
was mit den bots los
gefahren von bots oh das kodra visier ist broken
ok das mit dem spotten funktioniert irgendjemand hat einen triple kill streak übrigens ah
moment mein eins muss man noch machen bevor ich es vergesse die anzeige triple kill streak
die anzeige könnte man ja eigentlich für alle machen dass es die leute wissen oder
ja aber dann könnte ich ich ammo refill hinten dran schreiben die kill streak anzeige wenn
einer einen fünfer kill streak hat das wäre eigentlich nicht schlecht ok jetzt muss er
mal fünf bots killen falls das falls ich es irgendwie hinkriege
habt ihr den slowdown gesehen wie es geruckelt hat einfach 5 fps
eine extra nachricht ja wir müssen extra nachricht machen extra nachricht die nur leute
angezeigt bekommen das machen wir jetzt gleich display notifications für alle was not event
player ist
das funktioniert natürlich nicht
ich kann nur nach team filtern aber ich kann nicht sagen nicht für diesen einen spieler
das ist natürlich blöd
ich habe ich ich schaffe es in diesem game nicht auf tage zu bleiben es ist unmöglich
für mich ich habe in keinem game so große probleme mit dem einfach nicht drin
ich kann nicht auf tage bleiben es geht nicht
werden sie geheiligtet das ist nice das finde ich cool
da ist er stellt jetzt stellen wir uns an
so wie viel haben wir jetzt
wie viele kills haben wir jetzt gehabt ich habe es jetzt nicht gesehen
ihre ammo refill wir haben ammo refill gekriegt ok nice
ammo refill ein kill brauchen wir noch
und wie viel leben haben wir jetzt
ach da sieht man
250 ok wir haben 250 leben und ich bin jetzt komplett geheiligtet auf der map wahrscheinlich
denke ich mal
ja lull
ja das ist nice aber guck mal ich werde jetzt auch geheilt
auf 250 wieder rauf ok das ist op das ist op as fuck
mit der zeit laufen da nur noch 250 250er leute rum
wobei das geht ja nicht
ja das ist leicht leicht op leicht op
vor allem sind die leute auch permanent geheiligtet guck mal
das uav spotting ist nur für gegner ok was auch immer
defeat das uav spotting ist nur für gegner dass die eigenen heiligere heiligtet werden
liegt daran weil gegner das auch bekommen
deswegen haben wir jetzt eigentlich xp bekommen
oh 360 doch so viel nice das hat ja richtig gelohnt
oder nur per killstri kurzer healer das haben wir davor
naja ich finde das durchaus ok dass man 250 hp bekommt man ist ja permanent markiert auf
der map
das ist eigentlich in ordnung ok dann gehen wir mal raus
diesen komischen message ist weg jetzt wie kriegen das geht glaube ich nicht
wir kriegen keine message angezeigt die nicht den
doch ich weiß wie wir das machen können nein battle royale ist damit definitiv nicht
möglich wir können eine schleife machen über
alle spieler es sind alle immer gespottet naja das liegt
wahrscheinlich daran weil dreier kill streaks relativ häufig erreicht werden
das ist wir müssen jetzt hier nicht mit balancing sachen anfangen
aber wie könnten wir eine message machen die ich muss eine schleife machen
ich muss eine schleife machen über alle spieler die not event player sind
probieren wir mal aus jetzt ist halt dumm dass die subroutines keine
parameter haben dann könnte man das gut damit machen sonst sonst halt nicht
wo ist die schleife da also ich glaube hier muss ich wirklich
kein programmierer gedanken machen dass man hier von arbeitslos wird
message message spot kommt weg ok jetzt wie machen wir die message dass
die nicht an den event player geht also get all players not equal tut es war es
eigentlich
ich bin verwirrt hat die kunde
null big low brain low brain aber nicht so der logic nie dafür nicht also
current element get not equal event player
ja an alle spieler die nicht nicht der der spieler sind bekommen jetzt die
message ach nee moment das ist glaube lupe da
brauche ich eine andere variable für jetzt es ist so umständlich mann das ist
brutal ist umständlich message message vom null to count off den kram und jetzt
message schicken an index oft wie war das noch mal value in array oder not not
not so poggers würde ich sagen
not so poggers guckt euch das mal an ausgeburt der hölle er was ist das dann
die zukunft des programmierens aber so was von filter index nee nee nee also
hier das da braun war value value get players not equal to current player get
variable layer hey glaube message gut nice
alles kontroll erst geschichte jetzt bekommen alle eine message und zwar
bekommen alle eine message das ist und hier mal streak das brauche ich das ist
zwar nur beim 5er streak ist und 5er streak und hier kommt der event player
rein so das sollte von der idee her so funktionieren nur mit dem unterschied
dass es nicht hier rein sollen sondern zu fünft so
go get him hat das emoji support das müssen wir checken wie wir müssen checken
ob das emoji support hat aber wahrscheinlich nicht
oh darf man nicht verwenden das geht bestimmt nicht mit emojis wir müssen
wir müssen checken ob das funktioniert also wenn jetzt einer um 5er kill streak
ist dann wird er kriegt er 250 prozent leben er wird gespottet für fünf minuten
und der gesamte server darf ihn baschen easy bei sie mir kommt der harrier nee ja
also wenn es nach mir geht schon aber das ist damit leider nicht umsetzbar ich
muss jetzt mal probieren ob das ding emojis kann wir machen jetzt
eine message alle 15 sekunden so alle 15 sekunden an alle das checken wir jetzt
ob das funktioniert
dort sind zehn minuten naja habe ich fünf minuten gesagt in zehn minuten
mal gucken ob sie emojis anzeigen kann ich glaube nicht ich glaube nicht
aber nachdem da wahrscheinlich in den browser drunter ist mit html und css
unter hinter dem gui oder in der pause nein nope keine emojis kein emoji support
leute feels batman nope geht nicht
dann schmeißen wir das wieder raus
den zinger so was wie backslash n wahrscheinlich nicht
warum kann man das nicht voneinander lösen das ist total bescheuert das mit
dem ausschneiden muss also ich würde sagen für so kleines experiment ist das
doch ganz ok kann man sich jetzt nicht beschweren
sonderlich große sprünge gehen damit allerdings nicht
refund kein emoji support da geht wahrscheinlich sogar durch
extended max naja doch ich kann die account könnte ich hochsetzen aber ich
ich bleibe lieber beim refill ist zuverlässiger
also ich finde es cool aber ganz ehrlich ich hatte jetzt da mehr spaß
dran als an battlefield 2042 selbst aber aber ernsthaft also so der ach ja
übrigens man kann leute auch nicht spotten wenn sie sich nicht bewegen
weil ich glaube man kann nicht mitbekommen ob gegner sich bewegen oder
nicht es gibt kein on move event und man kann es auch sonst irgendwie nicht
abfragen player koordinaten gibt es gibt es
glaube ich auch nicht auch nicht position oder so
ach oder doch das gibt es doch man kann das machen
das geht ich könnte ich könnte eine schleife laufen lassen und wer sich
nicht bewegt wer sich nicht bewegt kriegt eine ermahnung oder so das müsste
tatsächlich funktionieren
if camp genau
local to world position ich bin aber nicht ganz sicher wie man das immer
das ordentlich machen soll local to world position world to local position
ich weiß was herauskommen soll am ende das konvert provider local player
position to corresponding position in the world space ok das muss ich mir
merken das ist gar nicht mal so einfach zu
implementieren dann ich könnte mir quasi die die koordinaten rausholen für
für einen spieler also müsste dann quasi nummer so
theoretisch man müsste dann quasi wieder alle ops was ist ja er müsste dann
wieder alle spieler lupen das machen wir mal weg
dann müsste dann wieder alle spieler lupen count of get players ist ok
get players ist passt auf was war das get player get player state ane das ist
ob er lebt oder nicht vermute ich mal
also das ist egal also man müsste eine schleife machen über die players dann
müsste man hier die local position sich holen in der variable für die
jeweiligen für den jeweiligen spieler speichern und da müsste man schauen hat
er sich bewegt quasi in irgendwie in dem areal von keine ahnung mehr als fünf
metern und wenn nicht kriegt er eine warnung und wenn
nicht wird er halt gekillt
das geht das ist mir jetzt aber so aus dem stegreif bisschen zu kompliziert
dass jetzt noch dazu bauen und die rausfiltern die tot sind ja genau die
müsste man da müsste man hier genau da müsste man hier haben wir ja und player
und player deploy wenn er respawn wird das wieder auf null gesetzt weil sonst
stirbt er direkt wieder weil er sich ja nicht bewegt hat während er dauernd war
oder es wird 50 prozent hells abgezogen wenn er zu lang kämpft ja aber ganz
ehrlich in loschard tdm kämpft eh keiner aber das trotzdem eine coole
funktion finde ich nicht schlecht dass das das finde ich ist eine gute idee
überlege ich mir noch mal ja aber insgesamt also wie gesagt das macht
es hat mir mehr spaß gemacht als bettel viel 2042 selbst zu spielen
also es ist ganz weird in dem game ich treffe nix also es ist wirklich so so
wie soll ich sagen so schwammig ist das falsche wort so so unpredictable
vielleicht liegt aber auch einfach an den fps kein schimmer ich meine ich
habe natürlich schon mal ein boomer ppega ei mittlerweile aber in bettel
viel 20 42 ist richtig schlimm
hast du die links unter deinem tweet angeschaut welche
welche welche denn
das hier scheiß ficker ne was mit dem ppega m ach das hier ja das war ein
witz das war ein witz das ist garantiert auf
irgendwelche super schlauen reddit leute bezogen gewesen
ach die reddit links reddit wo sind hier reddit links
machen wir kurz aus section aber kurz den selber selber weg ist schon wo er
das leute das bett company 2 ist brauchen das fack
ich sehe keine reddit links wo sind reddit links
anderer post okay andere post das hier ja ja ja das aber ihr habt sie eben auch im
nahkampf gesehen ich treffe ich treffe dem game einfach nix
ja es ist krass es ist richtig krass das habe ich auch jaja aber das also das
könnte auch ein back sein das ist der gleiche back ist den ich habe dass das
eigentlich ein team ist und es nicht angezeigt wird durchaus möglich dass
das eigentlich ein team ist was nicht angezeigt wird erkennt man das also das
durchaus möglich dass es ein team ist auf der minimap werden wenn es verbackt
ist die team jetzt auch nicht angezeigt guck das siehst du bei mir hier der ist
auch nicht auf der minimap guck kein gegner also keiner auf der minimap kein
team hat kein gegner ja den einberg fix habe ich schon lecker habe ich schon
gemacht bevor es die ganzen videos gab irgendwie ja es hat was gebracht aber
so wirklich also wirklich precise die battle viel drei bei mir ist es einfach
nicht kann mich da kann mich kann da nix kann da nix machen
das liegt aber glaube ich an den inkonsistenten fps glaubt das größte
problem deswegen kommt es einem so schwammig vor ich habe so ich mache ich
mache so krassen scheibenwischer in dem games in keinem anderen spiel mal
abwarten nächste woche wenn das game offiziell dann quasi herauskommen kann
man nicht sagen wenn es dann für die nicht preorder plebs da ist also nicht
aus wenn das game den early access verlässt sozusagen meta kritik das
müssen wir mal gucken aber grundlegend wird sich da ja auch
nix ändern
so als ganz okay loll user score dass du das dürfte nicht rating sondern es
müsste rantings heißen ob jetzt noch scoreboard ja ich habe das game ja auf
englisch aber ich habe jetzt schon einige leute gelesen die sich darüber
beschweren dass gegendert wird in der deutschen version kann ich beurteilen ob
das wie schlimm es ist aber es haben sich ein paar beschwert aber ich habe
die games eh auf englisch also ist es egal und mich wird es wahrscheinlich auf
deutsch je nach je nachdem wie es gemacht ist auch nicht wirklich großartig
stören ja lieber soldat in soldat ja das verstehe ich auch nicht zumal man ja
hier platz hat man hat ja platz also man könnte hier ohne probleme soldat
soldatin oder so schreiben die einzige stelle wo ich irgendwie so mal gender
schreibweise benutze ist wenn ich halt auf twitter irgendwas schreiben will und ich
habe nicht genug zeichen limits mehr dann mache ich das sonst mache ich das
eigentlich nie tricks hat gerät über das geht der rätst über alles das gehört
dazu ich kann es mir schon so richtig vorstellen die option an und aus geht ja nicht weißt du warum das
nicht geht weil sich dann die leute die dafür sind darüber schützt dort dass
man das ausschalten kann die sagen dann so nach dem motto das ist die einzig
richtige angehensweise da ist biedert sich hier den hatern an warum kann man es
ausschalten die ewig gestrigen eke kennt das leute vergesst das ist das thema ist
so unsinnig heißt diskutiert das ist der wahnsinn
es gibt doch klar der hat irgendwie was weiß ich 15 milliarden zuschauer auf
twitch warum machst du bei der ul immer die eins hin und wieder weg da haben wir
sogar ein kommando zu machen aus rufe zeichen eins ausgeschrieben im chat da
gibt es ein kommando zu wo ich das erkläre also ich bin mal gespannt was
nächste woche ist wenn das game rauskommt das spiel hat ja viele bugs das
problem ist für mich mit dem game nicht mein ppega aim oder so man das ist für
mich ein problem aber nicht kein geben von dem game an sich
nee aber was ich mit dem spieler für ein problem habe ist selbst wenn die
diese bugs die es jetzt gibt fixen also wende wo du durchlaufen kannst ja
irgendwelches rumgeklitsche nicht wiederbelebbar sein unkillbare drohne in
portal selbst wenn sie das alles ficken fixen ich habe ich versprochen das war
jetzt tatsächlich keine absicht selbst wenn sie das selbst wenn sie das alles
fixen dann ist der kern von dem game immer noch nicht gut
man muss sich mal angucken was in all out warfare drinne ist sieben maps und zwei
spielmodi also das ist ja der kern der ganzen sache portal schön und gut ja
hazard zone schön und gut aber der kern dessen was battlefield muss man sich auch
mal die letzten teile über angucken ausgemacht hat und das was die leute sich
eigentlich unter dem battlefield vorstellen ist eben war fair und da
gibt es nix das ist sehr schwach was da dabei ist es gibt zwei große maps und
128 spieler das aber auch das einzige was was es gibt es gibt viel gelände die
maps selbst sind ja nicht wirklich großartig ich würde noch nicht mal
sagen dass die map sonderlich aufwendig gemacht sind die maps sind einfach nur
groß mit viel gelände
und ansonsten ist nicht viel da zwei spielmodi wovon breakthrough nicht
spielbar ist auf der hälfte der map weil es einfach nicht passt dazu
teilweise ganz gut auf kaleidoskop zum beispiel finde ich breakthrough durchaus
ok aber ansonsten ist halt einfach nix drin ich weiß deswegen verstehe ich
manche reviews nicht so nach dem motto es ist die größte battlefield packungen
seit aller zeiten nee ist es nicht ist es gar nicht der kernspiel modus also
sprich all out warfare sieben maps mit sehr viel gelände und eigentlich ziemlich
wenig drauf insgesamt also spannendem nicht sonderlich viele waffen auch das
ganze attachment und equipment meta nenne ich jetzt mal ist ja nicht
vorhanden es gibt jetzt specialist ok wo sich aus
meiner meinung noch zwei stück raus kristallisieren die einfach richtig
krass sind nehme ich das ist für alle die aber so auf so war ability stehen die
nehmen maria falck und alle anderen die die krass beschen wollen nehmen webster
für grappling hook die anderen aber auch coole sachen aber so op technisch ist
das halt das eine und was ich was mir sie was ich mir komplett entzieht vom
verständnis her ist warum man auf die glorreiche idee gekommen ist diese
laut out geschichten so zu machen hätte man die specialist gemacht ich sage
euch jetzt mal meine ansicht ich sage mal wie ich mir das eigentlich
ursprünglich dachte mit den mit den specialist ich dachte die specialist
gehören einer klassischen battlefield klasse an ja maria falck ist medic zum
beispiel webster ist engineer oder assault oder so auch immer so habe ich so
daher habe ich mir ursprünglich vorgestellt und dementsprechend
kommen die automatisch quasi neben ihrem main gadget mit einem für die
jeweilige klasse typischem gadget das bedeutet dann jeder medic kommt mit
der medic box und maria fall kann 100 prozent wiederbeleben das wäre der bonus
des specialist jeder engineer kommt mit einem wiederbeleben mit einem repair
tool wurde hier schon einmal repaired in diesem game
du wirst vielleicht ab und zu gerätzt aber repairt wirst du eigentlich nie die
glaube ich glaube es gibt keine repair tool überhaupt ausgerüstet hat und so
dachte ich mir das eigentlich ursprünglich und deswegen fand ich
diese idee gar nicht schlecht so worauf jetzt rausgelaufen ist deswegen
habe ich auch im allerersten video was im lost gemacht habe gesagt hey
eigentlich ist es doch gar kein so großen unterschied zu vorher jetzt
gibt es specialist die zu einem klassen kit gehören aber wo ist der
unterschied ob specialist oder customization in battle field 4 jetzt
ist es aber komplett anders geworden meiner specialist und kann das kit
auswählen was man will was ja eigentlich keinen sinn ergibt warum
warum wähle ich die medic oma kann die aber dann mit sniper und ammo box
spielen was ist das denn für eine kombination unlimited self viel ammo box
und sniper das ist der traum eines jeden in der ecke liegen campers den kannst du
hitten der kann sich selbst heilen wenn er genug ppega eint hat kann er sich
selbst ammo legen was hat man sich denn dabei gedacht
wer kam auf die idee selbst viel selbst ammo plus sniper ist irgendwie eine
großartige idee
ja ach ja du hast recht das ist auch was was mich auch persönlich ein bisschen
nervt sind ammo boxen ja wie spricht man überhaupt aus angel kann ja irgendwie
ammo ammo zeug resupplein oder so nee nee nicht angel dings irish kann ammo
boxen resupplein oder glaube ich habe es jetzt habe ich durcheinander gebracht
habe ich das war wie war das noch mal wer macht ammo boxen also nicht ammo
boxen ähm plates panzer plates ach per engine kann plates und ammo ok ja die
plates sind auch so ein ding das klingt eigentlich ganz nice aber sorgt für
total für den konsistenz ich habe schon die richtig geilen flanks gemacht smg
bäbä bäbäm drei leute weg weg gebäscht dann dann ziele ich auf den
vierten kill ihn ammo ammo pop ja break ich gehe auf den
nächsten ach und du denkst mir so fack der ist ja gar nicht tot
also das mit den platten finde ich ist auch keine so clevere idee in bed company
2 gab es ja sowas schon mal ähnlich mit company 2 zu keramik rüstung nur dass
du da auch magnum ammo hattest das heißt entweder hast du magnum ammo oder
rüstung gespielt was sich dann irgendwie wieder gecancelt hat das war
nicht so wild
aber wie man auf die idee gekommen ist unlimited sehr viel ammo box und sniper
zu machen verstehe ich nicht ja und jetzt mal geht mal davon aus das wäre so
gewesen wie ich ursprünglich gedacht habe ja jeder specialist hat ein festes
kit was zu seiner klasse passt ich meine es macht doch überhaupt keinen sinn
guck mal wenn man die medic oma spielt das ist eine medic oma warum kann die
als sniper mit ammo box rumlaufen also wenn man sagt das ist ein medic dann
sollte der medic haben und medic gadgets wisst ihr das ist das wie ich mir das
ursprünglich vorgestellt habe die specialist haben ein festes kit
dementsprechend musst du halt auch die specialist durchswitchen was dann auch
variety bisschen reingebracht hätte deswegen musst du die specialist
durchswitchen hast halt immer noch das klassische jeweilige kit gadget dabei
bf sound naja in battle field 2042 das sound ziemlich abgefuckt du hörst ja
beispielsweise gegner die 50 meter weg sind so alt stehen sind meter neben dir
und umgedreht
und es hat halt echt wenig das spiel also wie gesagt ich kann alle reviews nicht
verstehen die sagen die größte battlefield packung aller zeiten es ist
einfach es ist nichts drinne im kern modus oder kern modus ist nun mal
einfach all out warfare schön dass es portal gibt alles alles schön und gut
oder hazard zone aber der kern eines battlefields ist in dem fall der linke
knopf im hauptmenü und da fehlt so ziemlich alles was in battlefield aus
gemacht hat in der vergangenheit also ich bin wirklich sehr enttäuscht über
das gelb gucken wir mal was da nächste woche kommt wenn wenn es wirklich
released wird dann wird ja auf jeden fall noch ein fetter day one patch kommen
der halt bugs fix aber halt nicht die eigentlichen kernprobleme die ich in dem
spiel sehe das heißt jetzt übrigens nicht dass das nicht bestimmt leute
gibt denen das wirklich gefällt diese neue battlefield reimagined geschichte
da was ist ja für mich für mich hat es einfach zu wenig von klassischen
battlefield gibt bestimmt genug leute die das cool finden ich habe jetzt auch
schon welche gesehen die sagen hey das ist doch nice dass die maps so riesen
groß sind jetzt kann ich endlich mit meinem chapter irgendwie 50 minuten im
kreis fliegen wunderbar nein du kannst glaube ich auf
battlefield 3 rush ne ne gute frage weiß ich gar nicht
vielleicht kannst du auf battlefield 3 rush spielen kein schimmer
rush kannst du übrigens in portal auch selbst nicht nachbauen das funktioniert
es sei denn ist der support ist schon drin also mit dem rules editor kannst du
definitiv kein kein rush implementieren also du könntest jetzt nicht sagen ich
baue ich baue rush oder so was also wer hat sich hier grad gesehen also wir haben
jetzt hier ein bisschen was ausprobieren also das hier ist so ziemlich das maximale was
man machen kann alles was an gadgets spawnen killstreak
spawnen gadgets spawnen airdrops spawnen oder
fahrzeuge spornen oder irgendwas in der richtung geht gibt es nicht
kannst du kannst du nicht machen
kannst du nicht bauen wenn es das nicht gibt kannst du es nicht bauen
es sei denn ist halt drin also wenn das hier so ported ist in diesen in diesen
settings hier dann kannst du das machen ja was wenn du sagen kannst rush und dann
keine ahnung bed company oder oder dann geht es aber du kannst es halt nicht
selbst bauen angenommen du möchtest jetzt battlefield 1942 maps nehmen und da
dort rush einbauen und es hat da ist nicht schon gemacht dann kannst du in
diesem rules editor nicht machen dazu ist das einfach nicht mächtig genug da
kannst du wie gesagt das hier ist das im prinzip das höchste der gefühle was
du machen kannst
ich glaube gar nicht mal dass sie in battle royale machen wollten wisst ihr
was ich glaube ich glaube die wollten so eine art escape vom tarkov machen oder
hunt showdown wie es in hazard zone ist da passt ja auch deutlich also das
squad play und diese unterschiedlichen fähigkeiten der specialists ergeben ja
auch in hazard zone viel mehr sinn ich weiß nicht ob ihr schon mal bei hazard
zone streams geguckt habt da ist richtig da ist richtig team play und überlegung
dabei da passt das viel viel besser zusammen
die sache ist nur die nachdem das ding nicht free to play ist und das spiel
jetzt in so einem fragwürdigen zustand und eben so was competitive ist wie
hazard zone eh nur ein bruchteil der spieler anspricht sehe ich für hazard
zone in der aktuellen variant wenig zukunft vielleicht machen sie so free
to play keine ahnung also ich wüsste jetzt nicht wo da das also mich würde
es äußerst wundern wenn in zwei drei monat noch jemand großartig hazard zone
spielt und ich glaube ihnen ist dabei aufgefallen so fack ja das trägt nicht
alleine was wir hier bauen wir machen jetzt noch zwischtausend sachen drum
herum und zigtausend sachen drum herum so dass wir möglichst viele entwickler
drauf schmeißen können das war ja bei der entwicklung von
belvedere haben ja unglaublich viele mitentwickelt ich glaube es gab noch kein
battlefield wo so viele leute oder unterschiedliche studien unterschiedliche
leute und mitentwickelt haben von den anti cheat leuten bis mit bis die
need for speed leute für die fahrzeug physik und so was und deswegen hat man
es glaube ich auch so verstückelt dass man möglichst schnell was entwickeln
kann parallel mit möglichst unterschiedlich vielen leuten nur
leider fühlt sich das spiel jetzt halt eher so an als haben die parallel
aneinander entwickelt aber es hat niemand auf das große und ganze geachtet
also das drängt sich mir bei den spielern auf und ich habe mich wirklich
auf das game gefreut und ich ich habe mir echt gewünscht dass es das battlefield
ist was ich wieder spielen will und ich ich mochte ich also ich wollte das game
wirklich mögen also da dran liegt es nicht
der ab der ist euch mal aufgefallen wie op der hovercraft das hovercraft ding
ist auch so krasses teil nee holt sie nicht also portal lohnt sich null wenn du
jetzt also portal ist kein kaufgrund für das spiel portal ist eventuell ein netter
bonus aber sicherlich nicht der hauptkaufgrund für das spiel
wenn die wende hochfahren noch nicht aber ich kenne dass das so über die
häuser springen hat mit dem hovercraft magst du das spiel also nicht im
aktuellen zustand ist es nicht nicht mal ansatzweise an meine erwartungen
herangekommen warum muss denn eigentlich kritik jetzt mal jetzt ich ganz ganz
ernst gemeinte frage warum muss denn begründete kritik immer hätten sein
meint ihr wirklich ich habe auf das release gewartet und habe hier gesessen
habe gedacht jawoll ich suche mir jetzt alles raus was scheiße ist ich hasse
battlefield ich möchte dieses spiel hassen ich mache ich flähme das spiel
jetzt einfach nur sinnlos damit ich mal richtig hassen kann meint ihr wirklich
dass ich dass ich das gemacht habe ja ich meine ich habe doch gerade selbst
gesagt ich habe mich unglaublich auf das game gefreut und ich hätte mir so
gewünscht dass mir gefällt ist es ist alles automatisch wenn man es begründet
kritisiert hate mittlerweile das kein das verstehe ich auf twitter und youtube auch
schon immer nicht ist doch gar nicht so
ich wäre der glücklichste spieler auf der welt wenn das spiel geil gewesen wäre
aber ansonsten ich kann den den hasst den die leute haben schon verstehen ich
mein guck mal es wurde mit riesen tamtam angekündigt ja du hast gedacht du
kriegst das quasi die neue erfindung des rats in battlefield form und im
endeffekt ist aktuell ein ziemlich verbacktes ding dabei rausgekommen was
aber gar nicht aus meiner sicht mal das größte problem ist sondern dass der
kern einfach nicht gut ist der all out warfare kern sehr einfach nicht gut ist
da bringen die alle back fixes der welt nichts wenn du nicht grundlegende
änderungen macht grundlegende änderungen werden zum beispiel mal
gescheite maps
battlefield 4 war zur release auch kacke aber es backst und so was angeht aber
war battlefield 4 konntest du von anfang an einen guten kern sehen der einfach
hoffnungslos verbackt und und im arsch war in battlefield 2042 siehst du ein
kern der hoffnungslos verbackt ist aber wo halt auch nix nix drunter ist was man
irgendwie haben will
genau ja das ist das nächste die die entscheidung finde ich ehrlich gesagt
auch gar nicht sinnvoll
wo war es denn jetzt hier dass das der prinzipielle ansatz mit 128 spieler den
finde ich auch nicht sinnvoll ich meine warum muss man prinzipiell sachen die
wirklich gut funktionieren warum muss man die unbedingt fixen der vorteil von
128 spieler mag sein dass man jetzt sagen kann cool wir machen größere maps
am 128 spieler aber muss ich mal überlegen was man sich quasi was man
sich da was man sich da an dadurch erkauft quasi 128 spieler heißt im
endeffekt klar du musst die maps größer machen logisch das genauso wie du
gesagt hast die sache ist nur die mehr spieler und größere maps machen das
gameplay nicht automatisch besser und das känzelt sich ja auch nicht also es
ist jetzt ja nicht so dass du sagen kannst 128 spieler größere maps ist
quasi wie kleinere maps mit 64 spieler das ist ja gar nicht so also die 128
spieler auch bei der aktuellen map größe ist so dass es oftmals darauf
rausläuft jetzt haben wir außer jetzt auf break
wie ist das breakaway breakout die an aktes map in der mitte bei diesen
nation treibhäusern oder was das sein soll da ist ja immer was los aber aus im
äußeren teil der map da läuft es im prinzip auf folgendes raus du flängst
fünf minuten irgendwo rum gehst an eine flagge es ist niemand da du fängst an
die flagge die flagge zu capen und auf einmal spornen 40 leute an der fahne
das ist einfach nicht durchdacht es ist entweder nichts los oder clusterfuck oder
halt normale action mitte der map
deswegen würde ich sagen mehr spieler mehr map ist nicht unbedingt das beste
vor allem was mir halt überhaupt nicht einleuchtet ist
konquest rush oder meinetwegen wie es ist breakthrough wie auch immer man es
senden mag oder jetzt auch operation jetzt es gibt so ein paar kerndinger was
die leute im kopf mit battlefield verbinden und was auch gut funktioniert
hat warum muss man das quasi warum muss man sich da was komplett neues ausdenken
was überhaupt nicht gut funktioniert wenn man doch was hat was wirklich gut
ich habe das gefühl die fangen bei jedem battlefield irgendwie bei null an was
ja eigentlich bescheuert ist und innovationen um des innovationens willens
also einfach dass man sagt hey wer macht was nur um es zu machen und alles zu
machen sind ja keine innovationen innovationen sind irgendwas was quasi
die sachen verbessern will oder oder verbessern im endeffekt was es das nicht
macht und man hat ja in den letzten battlefield teilen gesehen dass sie
schon auch gerade in battlefield 5 dass sie schon ein bisschen probleme hatten so
im dass sie ein bisschen gestruggelt haben am anfang auch so wirklich so dass
das kern battlefield gameplay wieder richtig gut hinzubekommen ist ja hey
mittlerweile ist das ist das echt nice ja ich habe von vielen gehört dass sie
auch battlefield eins nach einer weile wieder richtig richtig gut
reingesuchtet haben aber wenn man noch eh schon ein bisschen
probleme hat so die kern battlefield formel hinzubekommen dann so was
komplett neues rauszuholen ist ja doppelt bescheuert
also ich ich verstehe es nicht so genau was da management technisch gelaufen
also den leuten den ich auf jeden fall keinen vorwurf machen würde sind die
die da drin mit programmiert haben oder so ja das war weder denen ihre
entscheidung dass das spiel so verbuggt rauskommt noch haben die quasi großen
einfluss auf die gesamtvision des games also wenn man da jetzt sagt alter da ist
kann ich ordentlich programmieren ne das stimmt nicht können sicherlich
ordentlich programmieren und ich kann sicherlich auch gut und clevere sachen
progress gar keine frage aber was hat denn so normaler entwickler selbst
selbst normale teamleiter und vielleicht auch ein bisschen management leute da
auf so ein gesamtprojekt wirklich für ein einfluss gar nichts die können was
sagen oder wird wird in also wenn sie glück haben sie dürfen überhaupt was
sagen wird ihr dann gesagt ach ne passt nicht oder wollen wir nicht oder haben
wir keine zeit oder was auch immer also wenn ich so wie ich mir portal heute
angeguckt habe sehe ich das nicht also damit portal das mein geht mein geht
komplett ablös man darf nicht vergessen dass portal auch battlefield 2042 engine
ist mit den problemen die es aktuell gibt aktuell ist es so die haben zwar
so was wie battlefield 3 und bed company 2 trinne aber gerade bed company 2 hat
nichts aber auch gar nichts mit bed company 2 zu tun
es sieht so aus aber es spielt sich null wie bed company 2 spawn point sind
woanders die map layouts passen nicht richtig die gadget timings sind
anders das springen funktioniert nicht richtig
die drohne ist unzerstörbar zu zerstörbar also dass in der jetzigen form
und in dem jetzigen also wie viel du mit diesem editor machen kannst sehe ich
nicht dass portal überhaupt irgendwo hingeht ich meine das ist cool ja du
kannst so one in the chamber erstellen gun games erstellen sowas ist schon nice
aber das ersetzt einfach nicht den kern spiel modus und das ist eben was sie
jetzt all out warfare getauft haben das wird kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass
es das ersetzen wird
ja genau ich gehe davon auch dass es ich gehe auch davon aus dass es daran
liegt jetzt überlegt euch mal das game sollte ja eigentlich im oktober raus
kommen überlegt euch mal das game wäre im oktober rausgekommen
dann hätten wir quasi die beta version als release bekommen das spiel ist jetzt
schon kaputt ohne ende wir haben die beta version bekommen das wäre ja komplett
grip wobei ich witzigerweise sagen muss das reine gun handling hat mir
tatsächlich in der beta hast du auch nicht irgendwie also in der beta hatte
ich deutlich weniger probleme gegner zu treffen und es ging irgendwie auch
gefühlt mehr rein und es ist nicht jeder mit panzer platten rumgelaufen
also das reine das reine run and gun hat mir tatsächlich lustig in der beta
sogar noch besser gefallen
wo wir am laufenden band die 40 plus kill games 40 plus kill games hatten
ja weil niemand perfekt programmiert ich weiß wie es gemeint ist aber es ist
ja klar gerade unter zeitdruck und mit wechselnden ansagen vom management ist
natürlich schwierig und natürlich was man auch nicht vergessen darf ist dass
das schon eine gewisse komplexität hat also ich denke nicht dass es easy ist
das zu überblicken dass da fehler gibt ist ja normal
da müsste das game halt nicht rausholen wenn es noch so viele fehler hat das
kann das kann ich nicht beurteilen das können wahrscheinlich die meisten
anderen auch die das immer behaupten nicht beurteilen dazu müsste man mal an
einem dais game oder an dem need for speed oder hat fifa nicht auch frostbite
mittlerweile da müssen wir mal an einem frostbite game mit entwickelt haben und
die tools kennen und wie das so ist ich glaube das kann man so pauschal nicht
sagen es gibt ein paar berichte dass ich die need for speed leute übelst
ausgekotzt haben und die fifa leute glaube ich mal ausgekotzt haben wie sehr
frostbite shooter optimiert ist und sagt für alles andere eine ahnung kann man so
nicht sagen
ja aber nicht mal lang ich muss gleich pizzer futtern
ja genau zwei sieben maps ok ja sieben maps ist vielleicht nicht der wahnsinn
aber sieben maps ist in ordnung aber sieben maps mit quasi nur hügeln und
kaum sachen drauf ist vielleicht nicht ganz so spannend aber nur zwei spiel
modi wovon einer nämlich breakthrough komplett bronken ist auf der hälfte der
map naja also wer sich da gedacht hat das
reicht kein schimmer und service game hin und her
auch service games müssen erst mal gut starten
ok ich habe rainbow six vergessen ok service games müssen nicht gut
starten sie brauchen auf jeden fall irgendwie einen guten kern und den sehe
ich nicht es kann ja nicht sinn und zweck der sache sein dass man das game
rausbringt kaum was drinnen ist es noch verbackt ist ohne ende und dann
irgendwann über die nächsten zwei jahre es dahin bringt dass es spielenswert
ist das menü ist auch müll ja also schlimm
die war nicht agil genug ich glaube die waren zu agil ich glaube die waren zu
agil und so viel parallele leute sachen parallel gemacht ohne ohne genug dass
man wie soll man sagen und dass da genug einer regie geführt hat quasi als da
die gesamte vision beachtet wird wenn man dann jemals eine hatte
ja gut bei need for speed schuld und schock danke für den sub bei need for speed
ist er auch alles verlorne
ja ripp
ey battlefield lief also die letzten teile sowohl eins als auch gerade
battlefield fünf die sahen richtig gut aus die haben auch irgendwie was also
gerade ich habe nicht viel battlefield fünf gespielt ja das wisst ihr ja ich
habe ich habe ein paar videos zugemacht das war es aber battlefield fünf hatte
liebe zum detail das kann man nicht sagen also das kann man zu
battlefield 2042 irgendwie nicht sagen laufe da mal durch gebäude durch da
denkt ihr dass warum sieht sie auf shanghai besser aus als battlefield 2042
jetzt nicht rein von den effekten her sondern von irgendwie den gebäuden den
straßen in alles
und das kann man battlefield 5 wirklich nicht nicht anlassen also battlefield 5
hatte was maps und umgebung angeht schon liebe zum detail die ich bei 2042 bei
2042 wirkt für mich so als hätte man die maps zu 70 prozent aus einem terran
oder tränken alter terra dings also spricht man das überhaupt richtig aus
ihr wisst was ich meine ja dass man es aus so einem generator geholt hat der
halt eben berge und dünnen und so also als quasi so einem environment generator
geholt hat und genau und dann hat man ein paar sachen drauf gepappt und ist ein
bisschen angepasst so wirken die die 2042 maps bei mir ja stimm das
vergesse ich ja auch immer wieder es gibt ja noch nicht also das game hat eh
schon wenig zu bieten und eine kampagne ist ja auch nicht drin
also hatte battlefield 5 deutlich mehr liebe zum detail und auch mehr sehler
als jetzt 2042 chat ihr verfolgt das ihr verfolgt das doch ein bisschen mehr als
ich wie kommt das spiel so bei streamern an beim lost weiß ich der finns glaube
ich ganz ok ist aber auch zwischendurch mal ganz gut am flamen
ansonsten habe ich eigentlich kaum was mitbekommen
wisst ihr das wie kommt wie kommt das so allgemein an
schock sehe ich genauso ich habe auch also amis streamer vielleicht aber ami
youtuber habe ich schon genug gesehen die gesagt haben drauf so ich bloß nicht
kugelmagnet eddie ist begeistert echt der ist doch sonst immer super überkritisch
bei den ganzen ganzen sachen oder ist es jetzt jebait oder mag er das ich habe
nur ein paar videos von ihm gesehen dass er das immer alles sehr super kritisch
sieht definitiv ein echtes battlefield ok beta highlights
every minute
definitiv ein echtes battlefield ok
das ist mal so so unterschiedlich können die meinungen da sein
was gefällt ihr nicht habe ich mir die letzten halben stunden darüber ausgelassen
das werde ich jetzt nicht noch mal alles erzählen
amazing dange für den sub meinste gerade die die gerade damit anfangen kann ich
nicht vorstellen dass sie das gut finden
ja da hat er nicht unrecht gerade mit den mit den armor plates ist das so ein
ding aber er trägt sich auch mittlerweile schon ein bisschen älter
bei dem geht bestimmt wie bei mir auch schon das pp gar eben los jetzt nicht
seit dem chat hat einer bock drauf soll heute ich gehe jetzt pizzerfutter war
schön dass ihr dabei gewesen seid ich guck gerade haben wir irgendwie hosten
kinder los da 1000 extra zuschauer da brauchst auf jeden fall nicht ich werde
auch von hier bezahlt das ist problem ich habe hier gesagt oder der agentur die
die die das machen gesagt ich mache euch drei battlefield videos ich weiß gar
nicht was ich da machen soll ich kann doch jetzt nicht battlefield videos machen
bei dem game was ich mega beschissen finde also ich mache auf jeden fall ein
video zu portal mit dem material aus dem stream heute rest muss ich ich werde die
morgen fragen ob die wirklich wollen dass ich da videos zu machen weil ich mir
fällt schwer da ein gutes haar an vielen teilen von dem game zu lassen ja so
könnte man das wirklich sagen
ich spiel der belvin 2042 oder spieler bf3
noch sehr kennels was sonst nur und sonst natürlich spieler bf3 in 2042
der beste mal auf den 60 geht im one patch warten ja vielleicht kriegen sie
noch die kurve wie gesagt ich wäre der glücklichste spieler wenn das game
geil wäre weil es gibt ja sonst nix also battlefield
technisch es gibt ja immer noch gute spiele zwischendurch aber schon mal was
wehen
hier gibt es noch kein video zu ich glaube so ein abschließendes fazit video
mache ich auch erst wenn das spiel rauskommt am 19 das das werde ich dann
irgendwie nennen irgendwie schön clickbait titel aber muss natürlich auch
sinnvolle sinnvolle inhalt sein gut portal spielt sich träge weil es im
kern bf2042 engine ist auf bf3 bfbc2 gemacht
ja genau so sehe ich das auch ist das noch battlefield ja das mache ich das
sowas habe ich auch gedacht den titel spielter krieger bf das muss ich mir
angucken wenn einer noch größeres ppega aim hat als ich dann dann der krieger
ok zeig her das muss ich muss ich muss kurz gucken ich kann den haus ja ich
hauste ich wir werden den gleich ich war schon mal ich war schon mal ich muss ich
muss mir aber noch mal ich muss mir das originale kriegern gerade noch mal kurz
geben die runde ist gerade vorbei seck jawoll zeigst mir das muss jetzt ich
muss ich muss es sehen ich muss einfach sehen geht nicht anders
achso das ist ja playstation vergesse ich gerade natürlich dann ist wieder
rechts läuft den einer das ist kann sie dann ähnlich
vergleichen bär ja so dumme tode kenne ich ich komme mir rein den kriegern
warum ich lange nicht mehr gehört so rate zack
könnt ihr alle mal eine runde woop gas um spammen oder irgendwas in der
richtung also leute macht es gut wir sehen uns bis
dann zu